JOINING US I ASSUME THEY'RE
PEOPLE JOINING US VIRTUALLY
SINCE WE CAN'T SEE PEOPLE HERE
AS AS MANY PEOPLE HERE- WELCOME
TO ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER SIX ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR KOBE EIGHT
NINETEEN EXPENDITURES FEDERAL
FUNDS IN THE FEDERAL. THIS
HEARING USES TECH G. TO TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM PALACE REMOTELY
AND PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE OR- A PORTAL IN
CAPITAL PARK SO WE HAVE A
POORLY CAPITOL PARK. ON WHERE
YOU CAN GO AND TESTIFY.
REMOTELY AND IT COMES SO MUCH
CLEARER AND I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE BIT EASIER TO USE THAN
THE TELEPHONE BUT THE
TELEPHONES AVAILABLE FOR
ANYBODY WHO'S NOT. HERE LOCALLY.
AND I WANT TO REITERATE MY
THANKS FOR OUR ASSEMBLY STAFF
ARE BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF- MY
PERSONAL CPAP BUT ALSO THE
SPEAKER STAFF ASSEMBLY RULES.
THE ASSEMBLY STARTERS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER- IT
FEELS LIKE YESTERDAY THAT WE
WERE HERE ON APRIL TWENTIETH
WHEN WE WERE. SORT OF WALKING
INTO UNCHARTERED TERRITORY AND
SINCE THEN YOU SEEN THAT THE
ASSEMBLY BEEN ABLE TO OPERATE.
AS WELL AS A CAN BE UNDER THE-
VERY DAY. CIRCUMSTANCE SO JUST
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. THE DAY IN
FORTY TWO A TWO WERE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT- IN PERSON
HERE. EVEN THOUGH THIS HEARING
IS THE LARGEST IN THE CAPITAL
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AT A PARTICULAR TIME.
WELL WE ASK THE PUBLIC IN THE
MEDIA WE ARE SEPARATED AT LEAST
SIX FEET APART. I WELCOME THE
PUBLIC IN THE MEDIA TO ALSO
STATE SIX FEET APART WE'RE
PROUD MISSED AT HEARING TO
THOSE VERY STRICT
DISINCENTIVES. ALSO THE STATE
PUBLIC THAT ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WAS TO SPEAK
THEY CAN RAISE OUR HANDS ARE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICRO IN
INCOME FOR TO THE MICROPHONE.
WITH KNOWLEDGE. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL ACKNOWLEDGE
ALL THE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT'S
EITHER IN CAPITAL PARK OR ON
THE PHONE. I WOULD ALSO. ASK
THE PUBLIC TO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE TO. MAINTAIN
PHYSICAL DISTANCE FROM THE
MIGHT. AND THEN TO PLEASE EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'VE
MADE YOUR- MAJOR STATEMENT. I
ALSO ALL OUR PANELISTS ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY WE SEE THE
LA OWES PEERING REMOTELY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HEARING
REMOTELY- IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
COMMENT JUST TO REITERATE WE
ARE USING OUR PHONE LINE YOU
CAN CALL IN. 287-769-2895 SEVEN.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO EIGHT
THREE FOUR THREE EIGHT YOU'LL
SEE THAT ON ASSEMBLY ON THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE. ALSO IF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO PHYSICALLY
COME DOWN TO THE CAPITAL THERE
IS A STATION IN CAPITAL PARK
WHERE THEY CAN TESTIFY- IF
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE NUMBER
OF THE HEARING ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS JUST SEARCH FOR
CALIFORNIA. ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE SIX AND
YOU CAN SEE THE HEARING THE
HEARING PHONE NUMBER THERE YOU
COULD ALSO BE VIA EMAIL SO IF
YOU DON'T WANNA. SO ON THE
PHONE FEEL FREE TO EMAIL US
WITH TAKE YOUR COMMENT THAT WAY
AS WELL. THANK YOU HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE OUR COMMITTEE
OFFICE A CALL AT NINE ONCE. TWO
ONE. TWO ZERO NINE NINE. EVERY
PERSON EITHER ON THE PHONE OR
IN CAPITAL PARKER HERE IN
PERSON WILL BE GIVEN ONE MINUTE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. ON THOSE
WATCHING THE HEARING VIA LIVE
STREAM SHOULD KNOW THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A DELAY THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT A FEW SECOND LINE.
BETWEEN THE FOR THE ACTUAL
HEARING AND MAYBE WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING ON THE PHONE WHICH
WHICH WILL NOT HAVE THAT LACK.
I WILL BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER ALL THE MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS AT
THE HOUSE OF MAJOR STATE BUT
AGAIN. YOU WANNA REACHES VIA
EMAIL IS BUDGET SUB SIX. THE
WORD BUDGET SUB S. U. B. THE
NUMBER SIX AT A S. M. DOT C. A.
DOT GOV. I JUST DID BEGIN WITH
THE AGENDA TODAY- ANY MEMBER
WISHING TO MAKE OPENING OPENING
COMMENTS WILL BE ALLOWED TO DO
SO WE HAVE ONE PANEL TODAY WE
HAVE PALACE FROM THE LA. TO
WALK US THROUGH THE MUSCLES AND
THEN WE ARE FROM
ADMINISTRATION- DISTRIBUTION
MEMBERS TO PROVIDE BRIEF
COMMENTS ON. WHAT THE PANELS OF
FINISHED WILL ASK THAT THE
MEMBERS CAN ASK ANY QUESTIONS
AND FINALLY ONCE THE MEMBERS
FINISH THEIR QUESTIONS WE WILL
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE ROOM AND
THEN WE WILL END UP TO THE- ON
THE PHONE AND VIA VIDEO IN ALL
PARKING SO WITH THAT LET'S TAKE
ROLE. MR TANK HERE THE TRUMP
CARD REGULAR. BLOOM BRO THERE
IS CHIU COOPER MISTER FONG.
MCCARTY MISTRAL COUNTY FAIR
DOCTOR OVER HERE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO TODAY WERE VERY EXCITED
TO BE HERE ON THE FRIDAY BEFORE
MEMORIAL DAY DOESN'T QUITE FEEL
LIKE MORE THAN THAT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK MOST OF US HAVE
PLANS AS WE NORMALLY WOULD BE
ALL THE MORE OF A RUNNING
AROUND TO RIDE THE EVENTS- BUT
TODAY WE ARE HERE TO FOCUS ON A
FEW PROPOSALS. REQUIRE IN THE
ADMIN SHOULDN'T GIVE DISCRETION
OVER FUTURE FISCAL DECISIONS
AND WHILE WE ARE REITERATED
FORTY ONE WE ARE. NOT BE OUR
TWO MONTHS INTO NINE SORT OF
LIKE I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE A-
HEY BEFORE THE NINETEEN AFTER
CO NINETEEN NOW IN THE AFTER
COME NINETEEN. WE'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO REFLECT HOW THE STATE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
FUNCTION- WHAT'S WORKED WELL IN
WHAT HASN'T. AGAIN I REALLY
WANT TO COMMEND THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS TEAM FOR WORKING VERY
VERY HARD TO FLATTEN THIS
CURVE. TO GET A PEOPLE EDUCATED
GET PEOPLE UPTO SPEED. THEY
SURE THATWE HAD PROPER
RESOURCES- HOSPITAL ROOMS
VENTILATORS PP TO REMOTELY.
MANAGE TO THIS PANDEMIC. BIT
BUT HAVING SAID THAT I KNOW
THAT. MYSELF AND MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FEEL THAT THE LET WE
WOULD LIKE THE LEGISLATURE TO
BE MORE INVOLVED IN THAT
PROCESS. WHEN WE WERE IN RECESS
I KNOW LL OF US WERE IN
CONSTANT CONTACT WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR COMMUNITY.
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION AND
WHILE WE KNOW IT WAS- EMERGENCY
FLOWING AS QUICKLY AS WE WOULD
LIKE. SO NOW THAT WE ARE INTO
THIS PANDEMIC IN WELL IN TWO
MONTHS. WE WANT TO RE EVALUATE
THIS PROCESS- TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAS WORKED. ABOUT WHAT HOW DOES
IT WORK REALLY LOOK TO THE
FUTURE ON WHAT THE PROCESS
SHOULD LOOK LIKE NO KNOWING
THAT THE PROCESS WAS NOT AS
SMOOTH AS WE WOULD LIKE- THE LA
HAS WRITTEN. HAS HAD A COUPLE
CLOSE I JUST WANTED TO STATE
THAT I THOUGHT REALLY
SUMMARIZED I THINK OUR FEELINGS
QUITE WELL- WHAT OTHER QUOTES
FROM THEIR ANALYSIS OF THE MAY
REVISION WAS WE ARE VERY
TROUBLED BY THE DEGREE OF A
FORTY. THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS REQUESTING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DELEGATE. SO
PARTICULAR I THINK WITH A
COUPLE GOALS TO. SET UP A
PROCESS OF MOVING FORWARD ONE
ONE ENSURE THE GOVERNOR. HAS
THE ABILITY TO DO HIS JOB AND
TO REACT PROPERLY IN THIS COVE
IT NINETEEN EMERGENCY. TWO WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT ONCE WE GET
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE OR IF WE GET
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE THAT THERE
IS A PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO
DEPLOY THOSE RESOURCES VERY
QUICKLY. AND IMMEDIATELY- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
FIGHT THIS PANDEMIC- BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS INCORPORATED
INTO THIS PROCESS I CAN ONLY
SPEAK. FOR MYSELF. QUITE OFTEN
LIKE THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
I HAD TO WATCH THE GOVERNOR'S
NOON PRESS CONFERENCE TO KEEP
UP TO DATE WITH INFORMATION-
THERE WEREN'T VERY MANY AVENUES
OUTSIDE OF THAT TO GET
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION- AND SO- WE NEED
TO HAVE A MUCH BETTER PROCESS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS A
WHOLE. ON NOT JUST MYSELF
INDIVIDUALLY BUT WITHIN. BODY
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE PART OF
THIS A STATES PROCESS AS WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT THIS
PANDEMIC. IN IN. LOT LAST I
THINK WE DO NEED TO FIGURE OUT
AND WE WILL BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT TO DO IN
TERMS OF THE FEDERAL TRIGGER. I
WAS CONCERNED THE STATE BAN ON
APRIL TWENTIETH WE CAME BACK
FOR THE FIRST TIME. ABOUT THE
CONSTANT USE OF THE JAIL B. C.
LETTERS. NOW THAT WE ARE HERE
AND BACK IN SEC WE BELIEVE OUR
I BOUGHT TO SEE I BELIEVE. THAT
WE SHOULD NOT BE USING THOSE
JAIL BC LETTERS FOR NEW
APPROPRIATION. THAT WE HAVE A
BUDGET PROCESS WE- DEMONSTRATED
VERY QUICKLY THE DAY THAT WE
RECESSED HOW FAST WE ACT. THE
GOVERNOR FORTY THAT HE NEEDED
WE DID OUR PART BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IT'S BEEN A TWO
WAY STREET IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATION IN IN TERMS OF.
ENSURING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS PROPERLY INFORMED AND THAT
ARE FEEDBACK HAS BEEN PROPERLY
IN CORPORATE. AND IT AGAIN JUST
TO REITERATE I THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S DONE A GREAT JOB IS
TEAMS AT A GREAT JOB AND I WERE
HERE AT THIS POINT WHERE. ALL
WE CAN START RE OPENING SIR
PARTS OF OUR ECONOMY I THINK
IT'S- BUT BUT I THINK THE
OVERALL QUESTION. HOW IS THIS
DIFFERENT. THAN MANY OF THE
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES THAT
WE FACE TODAY. I DON'T JUST
GIVE YOU TWO TWO PARTICULAR
STOCKTON TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
TWO LARGEST CAUSES OF DEATH IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
ONE WAS HEART DISEASE AND WE
HAD SIXTY TWO THOUSAND DEATHS
IN HEART DISEASE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. WE HAD FIFTY NINE.
THOUSAND DEATH. BUT THE CAUSE
OF CANCER IN THAT YEAR OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. YEP WE DON'T
HAVE A STATE OF EMERGENCY. ON
THOSE DISEASES THE GOVERNOR
DOES NOT HAVE COMPLETE
AUTHORITY TO DO WHATEVER HE
WANTS TO FIGHT THOSE. DISEASES
AND OUT WHILE THE PUBLIC IS
EDUCATED ABOUT WHAT THEY THEY
CAN AND THEY SHOULD DO WE HAVE
NOT TAKEN. MEASURES FROM AN
OVERALL STATE STANDPOINT TO
COMPLETELY- FIGHT THOSE
DISEASES WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
FERVOR THAT WE HAVE WITH
CALVET. NOW I'M NOT ADVOCATING
THAT WE SHOULD SHOULD VEER OFF
COURSE I THINK THE COURSE THAT
WE HAVE. BEEN ON IS ACTUALLY
CORRECT I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE A COURSE WHERE THE PUBLIC.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE BODY WHICH IS
CLOSE BODY ARE REALLY. OF THAT
PROCESS AND PART OF THAT
DELIBERATION IN PART OF. THAT
DECISION MAKING PROCESS SO.
WITH THAT LET ME ARE TURNED
OVER TO THE OUR VICE CHAIR OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. MR
OBERNOLTE AND THEN SEE IF OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS AND THOUGHTS MISERABLE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
THINK YOU'VE SUMMARIZE THE
ISSUE VERY CLEARLY THAT I
COULDN'T BE AND- GREATER
AGREEMENT WITH YOU THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN UNUSUAL AND VERY
INTERESTING HEARING. BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BEING
INVOLVED WITH CONTROLLING THE
PURSE STRINGS. IN THE EVENT OF
AN EMERGENCY AND WE'RE DOING
THIS HELLO OF OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH A VIRUS AND- WE'RE GONNA
BE. THE GOOD THE BAD. WHAT ARE.
A COUPLE OF MONTHS. GONNA BE OF
A LARGER JUST THE WE AS A HAVE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS NOW WHICH IS
THAT HOW DO YOU BALANCE
CENTRALIZE DECISION MAKING
AUTHORITY IN AN EXECUTIVE
BRANCH WITH THE DESIRE TO HAVE
THE PEOPLE'S REPRESENTATIVES
WAY- AND- IT'S VERY CLEAR IN
THE CASE OF BOTH THE UNITED
STATES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR LOOK AT OUR
CONSTITUTION. THE INTENDED TO
BE THE- CONTROLS THE PURSE
STRINGS. SO IT'S GONNA BE VERY
INTERESTING TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION TALK ABOUT WHAT WENT
RIGHT WHAT WENT WRONG OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS AND- MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO TALK ABOUT. HOW
WE'RE GOING TO STRUCTURE THIS
DECISION MAKING UP A THIRTY
GOING FORWARD SO I'M VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU I SURE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERSHIP. DOCTOR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
FOR CONVENING. THIS HEARING AT
THIS MOST CRITICAL TIME. LAST
WEEK OUR GOVERNOR SAID DURING
THE MAY REVISION OF HIS
PROPOSED A BUDGET AND I THINK
HE SUMMARIZED IT QUITE WELL.
WHEN HE SAID THIS IS NO NORMAL
YEAR THIS IS NO ORDINARY MAY
REVISION. AS CHAIR OF SOMEONE
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
I'VE BEEN CLOSELY FOLLOWING THE
EMERGENCY ACTIONS THE STATE IS
TAKEN TO MEET BOTH THE MEDICAL
AND ECONOMIC CHALLENGES OF THIS
PANDEMIC. I'VE SAID BEFORE AND
I WILL READ IT I BELIEVE THAT
INVESTMENTS IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS AND SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
OUR INVESTMENTS IN OUR ECONOMIC
HELP. AS WE EMERGE FROM THIS
PANDEMIC WE MUST ENSURE THAT WE
DO NOT LOSE PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE STRENGTHENING OUR HEALTH
CARE IN BROOKSHIRE. MOVING OUR
OUTCOME AND PROVIDING SAFE
HARBOR FOR ARE WORKING FAMILIES
THROUGH OUR SAFETY NET. I HAVE
BEEN HARMED. BY THE
COMPASSIONATE AND QUIRK ACTIONS
THAT ARE GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN
DURING THE COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS. AND THAT IS WHY I WILL
BE CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE FOR A
COMPASSIONATE FLEXIBLE BUDGET
AS WE WORK WITH OUR ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE COLLEAGUES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LAND A PUNCH.
AS WE LOOK CLOSELY AT THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORTH.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE LA-
IN THE COMMENTS PROVIDED BY THE
PUBLIC OUR PRIMARY DUTY IS TO
ENSURE. THE VITALITY. THE
HEALTH AND THE RESILIENCY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OF OUR
ECONOMY. WITH THAT FRAMEWORK IN
MIND I WOULD LOOK TO OUR
PANELISTS TODAY FOR ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE AND INSIGHT TO HELP US
TO CREATE THAT RESILIENCY
DESPITE THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE. THANK YOU DOCTOR ABOUT SO
WITH THAT WE ARE GOING TO START
OUR- HEARING AND. ARE WE DOING
I WILL FIRST WE'RE DOING THE
FINANCE FIRST HELLO AND ALSO I
FORGOT TO MENTION BUT- WE HAVE
ONLY A FIRST IF YOU COULD ALSO
I'M SURE THE READY IN YOUR
COMMENTS BUT JUST DIRECTLY
ADDRESSED THE NUMEROUS CONTROL
FUNCTIONS THAT ARE LITTERED ALL
OVER THE BUDGET. WHICH REALLY
AUTHORITY AWAY LEGISLATURE
AROUND NUMEROUS FUTURE
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MR VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND HAULING
SAID WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING TODAY FROM A HANDOUT
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU I'M AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOLLOWING ALONG HOME IT'S
AVAILABLE ON THE ASSEMBLY
WEBSITE OR AT ELLIE DOT CA DOC
OF. JUST TO. ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE. WHILE THIS CONVERSATION
IS PRETTY TECHNICAL AND PRETTY
PROCEDURAL AND I WILL- DISCUSS
IN DETAIL THE VARIOUS CONTROL
SECTIONS THAT ARE TO BE
PROPOSED- WE THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO START WITH WHY WE
VIEW THIS ISSUE I WAS SO
IMPORTANT- AT ITS CORE. THIS IS
REALLY A CONVERSATION ABOUT
BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE. AND THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. AND HOW MUCH THE
LEGISLATURE THINKS IS
APPROPRIATE TO DELEGATE TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IN THE CONTEXT
OF AN EMERGENCY. SO AT THE END
I'LL GIVE OUR OFFICES OVERALL
COMMENTS AND REALLY. THIS
QUESTION- THIS QUESTION OF
BALANCE. IS THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLE THAT WILL INFORM- THE
COMMENTS THAT I GET AT THE END.
BEFORE KIND OF DELVING INTO THE
CONTROL SECTIONS IN DETAIL LET
ME JUST GIVE YOU AN A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
CATEGORIES THAT THEY FALL INTO.
THE FIRST IS COAL BID RELATED
EXPENDITURES THE SECOND IS NEW
OR HYPOTHETICALLY NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WILL BE RECEIVED
BY THE STATE. AND THE THIRD ARE
FEDERAL TRIGGER SO MANY DISCUSS
EACH OF THOSE IN TURN AND THEN
GIVE OUR COMMENTS ABOUT ALL OF
THEM BROADLY AT THE END. SO
TURNING TO THE FIRST PAGE ARE
WITH- THE OVERVIEW OF
PROPOSALS. THIS OUR CONCERNS
CHIU DIFFERENT SOURCES OF
AUTHORITY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS USED TO BOTH
SPEND- OR ALLOCATE COALBED
RELATED EXPENDITURES TO DATE.
AND THEN WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THAT
THE STATE USE I'M ON A FUTURE
BASIS GOING FORWARD. THE TOP OF
THE PAGE SEE TABLE THIS JUST
SHOWS ON. THE STATE HAS SO FAR
SPENT TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. ON COVERT RELATE EXT.
THE THIRTY OF THE I IT IS
EXPECTING TO BE REIMBURSED FROM
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BOTH WHAT
HUSBANDS AND VOTE WHAT WILL BE
SPENT- BUT INITIALLY ALL OF
THESE EXPENDITURES ARE MADE
FROM. THE GENERAL. AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE TAPE YOU SEE WHY
IS BEING. AT THE TIME OF THE
MAY REVISION ON A FUTURE BASIS
AND SO THERE'S ABOUT THREE AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED- AS A DIRECT
ALLOCATION EXPENDITURE IN A
VARIETY OF AREAS ACTUALLY JUST
RECEIVED INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO
SPEND THIS THREE AND A HALF
BILLION AND THEN. IN ADDITION
THERE'S TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN WHAT'S CALLED THE
KOBE CONTINGENCY FUND OR A
COVERT RESERVE. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PROPOSING. SO THERE'S TWO
PIECES OF AUTHORITY ABOUT ARE
RELEVANT HERE THE FIRST IS
CONTROL SECTION THREE SIX OF
THIRTY SIX AND THE SECOND IS
THREE HOURS LET ME JUSTTALK
FOR EACH OF THOSE. CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX WAS PUT INTO
THE BUDGET BY SB EIGHTY NINE
SHORTLY BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
WENT ON TO RECESS. AND EXTENDED
RECESS ASSOCIATED WITH A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY IN. SO THIS
WAS IN MARCH- THIS- WAS
ACCOMPANIED BY A ONE OF BY UP
TO A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD BE USED.
WITH A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE SO
TO DATE O. HAS BEEN IT'S ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
BEEN SPENT. THE SECOND PIECE
THE RELEVANT AUTHORITY IS THREE
OH OUTAND THIS IS ACTUALLY A
MORE LONGSTANDING AUTHORITY
THAT ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION
TO TRANSFER MONEY OUT OF THE
STATE'S FLEXIBLE RESERVE
ACCOUNT THE SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES AND INTO
A SUB ACCOUNT KNOWN AS TRIO
I'M- AND UNDER TRIO- THE%
ADMINISTRATION BASICALLY JUST
HAS TO NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN THAT INITIAL TRANSFER
ISN'T. AN SO FOR ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN SPENT
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED UNDER THIS
AUTHORITY- AND WE ALSO RECENTLY
RECEIVED A BIT MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT EXACTLY HOW THOSE FUNDS-
TO WHAT PURPOSE THOSE FUNDS ARE
BEING DIRECT. NO IMPORTANTLY-
THE NEW FUNDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING AND
THE MAYOR OF VISION ABOUT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IS BEING
PROPOSED TO CONTINUE TO BE
ALLOCATED UNDER THAT CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX. A
NOTIFICATION PROCESS THAT THE
ORIGINAL ONE BILLION DOLLARS
WAS TO BE ALLOCATED UNDER.
TURNING TO THE NEXT PAGE.
MINUTES TALK THROUGH TO CONTROL
SECTIONS THAT ARE PROPOSED AND
THESE ARE REALLY ABOUT- NEW
FEDERAL FUNDING BOTH FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
GRANTED TO THE STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT IS
HYPOTHETICAL- AND POSSIBLE IN
THE FUTURE. SO THERE ARE AGAIN
TO CONTROL SECTIONS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED HERE THESE WOULD
BOTH BE ENTIRELY NEW PIECES OF
BUDGET LANGUAGE. AND THE FIRST
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN POINT
NINE ZERO- IS WITH RESPECT TO
HOW THE STATE WHAT ALLOCATE
NINE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
OF WHAT'S CALLED CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF FUNDS THIS IS MONEY THAT
WAS ALLOCATED TO STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BY CONGRESS
IN THE CARES ACT. AND
CALIFORNIA THE STATE GOVERNMENT
OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVED AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS THE TABLE
AT THE TOP OF THE PAGE JUST
SHOWS HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSING THIS MONEY
WOULD BE. ALLOCATED IN THE MAY
REQUEST PROCESS OF THE TOTAL
NINE AND A HALF ABOUT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS JUST UNDER FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS BUT HE DID TO
STATE BUDGET. I'M AND THIS
WOULD ESSENTIAL BE REPLACED%
EXISTING STATE EXPENDITURES
THAN FOUR BILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BE ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS FOR
HIGHER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR EXAMPLE
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TO COUNTIES. AND NEARLY A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS FOR CITIES
NOW IMPORTANTLY. ELEVEN POINT
NINE ZERO GIVES THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH- A GREAT DEAL OF
LATITUDE TO REALLOCATE THESE
FUNDS NOW- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT TO BE- THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION DOES REQUIRE THESE
FUNDS TO BE SPENT BETWEEN MARCH
FIRST AND DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR. SO IF
THE R. F. IS NOT SPENT IN THAT
PERIOD OF THE MONEY WOULD HAVE
TO GO BACK TO THE FEDERAL
TREASURY SO UNDERSTANDABLY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION VIEWS IT AS
IMPORTANT THAT ALL OF THAT FUND
OUT ALL OF THOSE FUNDS STATE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
BUT THE CONTROLS ACTION DOES
GIVE RESTORATION PRETTY BROAD
AUTHORITY TO REALLOCATE THE
FUNDS EVEN THOUGH IT MINISTRY A
LEGISLATURE WOULD ENACT PLAN.
GEN POINT. THIS SECTION A SENSE
INSIST THAT NEW FEDERAL FUNDING
COULD COME THROUGH TO STATE IN
YOU KNOW THE COMING WEEKS FOR
THE COMING MONTHS AND THIS
AGAIN ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS EITHER
FOR BUDGETARY RELIEF TO REPLACE
EXISTING GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES OR FOR YOU KNOW
NEW PURPOSES DEPENDING ON
WHAT'S ALLOWABLE IN- IN THE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION. THEY HAD
OUT NOTES THAT- NEITHER OF
THESE REQUIRE NOTIFICATION TO
THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY THAT
HAS CHANGED- OR AT LEAST OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT HAS
CHANGED- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING NEW
CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD. INVOLVE NOTIFICATION- SO
ACTUALLY THIS HANDOUT IS UP TO
DATE AS OF YESTERDAY MORNING-
BUT THERE ARE- THIS IS
CONTINUALLY EVOLVING PROCESS
AND OUR UNDERSTANDING CONTINUES
TO EVOLVE. SO ON THE THIRD PAGE
WE PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
FEDERAL TRIGGER LEGISLATION- OR
FEDERAL TRIGGER CONTROL SECTION
THAT IS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. SO ESSENTIALLY-
THE MAIN REVISION PROPOSES A
VARIETY OF SOLUTIONS TO SOLVE A
FIFTY FOUR POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLAR ON BUDGET DEFICIT. ONE
OF THOSE SETS OF SOLUTIONS IS
ABOUT FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN SPENDING RELATED REDUCTIONS.
THOSE ARE SHOWN AT THE TABLE-
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PAGE THERE.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS-
CONTROL SECTION WOULD DO IS SAY
IF FEDERAL LEGISLATION OR
FEDERAL FUNDING IS FORTHCOMING
IN THE COMING WEEKS OR IN THE
COMING MONTHS. THAT COULDPLANT
THESE- EXISTING POTS THEN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH WILL HAVE THE
POWER TO ESSENTIALLY RESTORE
THE CUTS THAT ARE MADE IN LAW.
AND THIS WOULD INCLUDE A
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
FOR OKAY. SO THE FOLLOWING PAGE
PROVIDES OUR COMMENTS. ONE
THING TO START WITH IS THAT HE
CONTROL SECTIONS THAT ARE
PROPOSED HERE DIFFER
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM EXISTING
BUDGET PROCESS SEES THAT ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE SO- PASSED
BUDGET AX HAVE ENVISIONED A
SITUATION IN WHICH- FEDERAL
FUNDING IS NEW AND ON
ANTICIPATED AND COMES AFTER THE
TIME THAT THE BUDGET IS PASSED
OR THAT THERE IS A EMERGENCY OR
THAT THERE IS A CONTINGENCY AT
A DEPARTMENT FOR WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS NEW MONEY.
THAT HADN'T BEEN CONTEMPLATED
AT THE TIME THE BUDGET WAS
ENACTED. THESE PIECES OF BUDGET
CONTROL LANGUAGE GENERALLY
INVOLVE A NUMBER OF
LIMITATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THEY
INCLUDE THIRTY DAY REVIEW
PERIOD BY THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THEY INVOLVE.
THEY SPECIFICALLY INVOLVED
LANGUAGE THAT PRECLUDES THE
SORT OF CONTROL SECTION PROCESS
FROM REPLACINGOR SUPPLANTING
THE EXISTING BUDGETARY PROCESS
THEY REQUIRE THE FUNDS TO BE ON
ANTICIPATED THEY REQUIRE THE
FUNDS TO NOT BE DISCRETIONARY-
SO THESE ARE JUST EXAMPLES OF
THELIMITATIONS THAT EXIST KIND
OF IN. JUST THE TYPICAL BUDGET
PROCESS FOR DEALING WITH THESE
THESE ISSUES. NOW THE
ADMINISTRATION PERHAPS
REASONABLY- VIEWS IN THIS AS
TOO RESTRICTIVE IN THE CONTEXT
OF- BE CURRENT EMERGENCY THAT
THE STATE IS FACING AND WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEN THERE IS A
NEED FOR SOME LEVEL OF
FLEXIBILITY THAT PERHAPS THE
EXISTING IN SOME CASES THE
EXISTING PROCESS THE STATE HAS
IMPLEMENTED. DOESN'T ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION TO RESPOND SORT
OF SUFFICIENTLY NIMBLY AND-
EFFICIENTLY AS IT WITH LIKE IN
THE IN THE CONTEXT OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. BUT THAT SAID THE-
PROPOSALS BY THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THESE AREAS GO LIKELY TOO
FAR IN SIDELINING LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY AND IN PRECLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
EXERCISE EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT
AND SO THOSE TWO AREAS
AUTHORITY AND OVERSIGHT ARE
REALLY AT THE PLACES WHERE WE
HAVE FOCUSED ON MOST AND LET ME
JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES FROM THE CONTROL
SECTIONS ABOUT ABOUT WHAT WE
MEAN HERE. SO OUT WITH RESPECT
TO AUTHORITY THE CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINE FIVE
THE ONE THAT- ANTICIPATES KIND
OF HYPOTHETICAL FUTURE NEW
FEDERAL FINES ESSENTIALLY
ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TAKE ON THE LEGISLATURE'S POWER
OF APPROPRIATIONS FOR THOSE
FUTURE FUNDS IN IN WHAT IS. I
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX
WHICH- WOULD IT BE THE CONTROL
SECTION THAT WOULD GUIDE THAT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN CAN
KOBE CONTINGENCY FUNDS REALLY
AGAIN WITH ONLY A SEVENTY TWO
HOUR NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WOULD ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION
TO ALLOCATE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN CALL AS LONG AS IT
WAS KOBE RELATED FUNDING REALLY
WITHOUT AIR AND DECISION MAKING
BY THE LEGISLATURE JUST
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THEN FINALLY- ELEVEN POINT
NINE ZERO THE ONE THAT CONCERN
TO THE NINE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN CORONA VIRUS RELIEF
FUNDS REALLY ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REALLOCATE
THOUGHT FUNDING- IN. IN ANY
MANNER AS LONG AS IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH ALL THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES DESPITE THE FACT
THAT A PLAN WILL HAVE BEEN
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
MID JUNE- FOR HOW TO SPEND
THOSE FUNDS. THEN JUST A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES IN THE OVERSIGHT
ROUND. SO THERE AREN'T ANY
SPECIFIC INFORMATION
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING-
ALLOCATIONS MADE UNDER CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX IN IN THE
CASE OF CONTROL SECTION THIRTY
SIX REALLY THE FUNDING-
REQUIRES A NOTIFICATION BUT NO
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ABOUT YOU
KNOW CONTRACTS OR WHAT- OR HOW-
VERY SPECIFICALLY THE FUNDS
WOULD BE ALLOCATED. AND THEN
SIMILARLY ON THE- JURY- OF-
AUTHORIZATIONS- ALTHOUGH THERE
IS A NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT
ABOUT WHEN THE FUND IS ARE
TRANSFERRED FROM THE STATE'S
FLEXIBLE RESERVE ACCOUNT THE
SFU TO JURY- OUT THERE IS NO
COROLLARY TO- CONTROL SECTION
THIRTY SIX WITH NOTIFICATIONS
ABOUT HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
ULTIMATELY ALLOCATED. AND WITH
THE CABBIE OUT THAT WE DID
RECEIVE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OUT YESTERDAY ABOUT
THIS LAST NIGHT ABOUT THIS- TO
DATE WE HAVE HAD VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SPENT. THOSE
THREE OFF FUNDS. SO THE FOR THE
NEXT PAGE PAGE FIVE PROVIDES
SOME OPTIONS AND WE REALLY VIEW
THESE OPTIONS AS- SEEKING TO
ACHIEVE A BETTER BALANCE
BETWEEN THE NEED FOR
ADMINISTRATIONS. FLEXIBILITY IN
LIGHT OF THE EMERGENCY WHICH WE
DO UNDERSTAND IS IMPORTANT BUT
ALSO THE NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY AND LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. SO I WON'T WALK
THROUGH ALL OF THESE OPTIONS IN
DETAIL BECAUSE THERE'S A NUMBER
OF THEM IN THE HANDOUT BUT I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT ONES. SO
FIRST JUST TAKING THE ONES
RELATED TO STATE SPENDING SO
THESE ARE REALLY ABOUT CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX AND THREE OH
UP- WE THINK THAT IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
PROCESS IN PLACE DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE IS IN
SESSION OR NOT IN SESSION. SO
SB EIGHTY NINE WAS ENACTED JUST
BEFORE THE LEGISLATUR WENT ON
AN EXTENDED RECESS IN RESPONSE
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
AND IT WAS ENACTED IN LIGHT OF
THAT SITUATION. BUT PERHAPS A
DIFFERENT NOTIFICATION PROCESS
OR EVEN A DIFFERENT PROCESS
ENTIRELY IS APPROPRIATE IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN SESSION- AND
IS ABLE TO ACT MORE QUICKLY%
THAN IT WOULD BE IF IT WERE OUT
OF SESSION. ON ELIGIBLE USES OF
FUNDS- JUST SOMETHING TO
EMPHASIZE HERE IS THAT THE
PANDEMIC HOUSE REQUIRED THE
STATE TO ENTER INTO VERY NEW
KINDS OF EXPENDITURES. NEW
KINDS OF CONTRACTS THAT- YOU
KNOW ARE ARE QUITE ATYPICAL FOR
THE STATE'S- ORDINARY COURSE OF
BUSINESS. AND UNLIKE WITH OTHER
DISASTERS FOR EXAMPLE A WILD
FIRE WHERE THE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES THAT THE STATE WOULD
TAKE ON ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
WILD FIRE QUITE KNOWN. IN THE
ACTUALLY QUITE
IN SEVERAL CASES THE- THE TYPES
OF EXPENDITURES AT THE TAKE THE
STATE IS TAKING ON A QUITE NOW.
AND SO- ONE OPTION FOR
CONSIDERATION WOULD BE TO
CONSIDER THE TYPES OF ELIGIBLE
FUNDS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
ALLOCATED UNDER DIFFERENT TYPES
OF AUTHORITY AND WHETHER IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO PLACE SOME
LIMITS ON THOSE TYPES OF
ELIGIBLE FUNDS. THE FINAL PAGE-
CONCERNS BE CONTROL SECTIONS
AND THE AUTHORITIES THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING IN PARTICULAR AND SO
THIS IS ELEVEN POINT NINE ZERO.
ELEVEN POINT NINE FIVE AND THEN
THE CONTROL SECTION EIGHT TWO
EIGHT. I GOT I WON'T WALK
THROUGH THESE IN DETAIL BUT
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF NOTES- THE PROCESS
AGAIN MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO BE
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON WHETHER
OR NOT THE LEGISLATURE'S AND-
IN SESSION. ON ON TYPICAL
CONTROL SECTIONS THAT THE STATE
HAS IN PLACE FOR DEALING WITH
ON ANTICIPATED FEDERAL
EXPENDITURES IT'S ACTUALLY
QUITE CLEAR IN BUDGET LANGUAGE
THAT IT IS NOT INTENDED TO
REPLACE THE BUDGET PROCESS SO.
THAT IS AN EXAMPLE OF A KIND OF
LIMITATION- THAT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE AGAIN IN THIS CONTEXT
DEPENDING ON. YOU KNOW HOW
QUICKLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS REQUIRING THE STATE TO SPEND
THE MONEY. AND THEN ALL THE
FEDERAL TRIGGERS IN PARTICULAR
SOMETHING THAT WE NOTED IN OUR
OVERALL COMMENTS TO THEM A
REVISION. IS THAT IF MORE
FEDERAL AID IS FORTHCOMING
PARTICULARLY IF SUBSTANTIAL
FEDERAL AID IS FORTHCOMING. IT
MIGHT MAKE SENSE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO RECONSIDER THE
ENTIRE STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET
NOT JUST- THE SPENDING
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
TRIGGER. AND SO IN THAT CASE-
PERHAPS MID YEAR BUDGET ACTION
WOULD BE WARRANTED IN STATEN.
FINALLY IT'S NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR
TO US WHAT WOULD HAPPEN. IF
LESS THAN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT IS NEEDED TO RESTORE THE
SPENDING CUTS ARE LESS THAN
FOURTEEN BILLION A FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. IS GIVEN TO
THE STATE- FROM FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
WOULD IT BE PRO RATED ACROSS A
VARIETY OF DEPARTMENTS WOULD-
SOME DEPARTMENTS RECEIVE CUTS
AND OTHERS WOULD NOT- THOSE
KINDS OF IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS BE CONTROL SECTION
LANGUAGE IS STILL SILENT TIM.
SO WITH THAT- I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS WENDY APPROPRIATE
MOMENT ARISES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- NOW WE'RE GONNA GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER TANG AND MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS VERY BRIEF TO RESERVE
THE BALANCE OF THE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS I WANT TO MAKE THREE
POINTS ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE FIRST IS
THAT THE UPDATED ESTIMATES-
THAT WERE IN THE NAY REVISION
OR ALSO REFLECTED IN THE LETTER
THAT WAS SENT LATE LAST NIGHT
OURSTAFF HAS BEEN WORKING. DAY
AND NIGHT TO CLARIFY THE
EXPENDITURES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW WE ARE
EXPECTING- NET GENERAL FUND
COST OF ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THESE EXPENDITURES
AND THIS REFLECTS- THE VARIOUS
STREAMS FROM THE SECTION THIRTY
SIX ALLOCATIONS UNDER SB EIGHTY
NINE. TO THE TRIO ALLOCATIONS-
AS WELL AS FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT THAT BEING SAID-
I DO WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS
IS A POINT IN TIME ESTIMATE-
THE COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC IN
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME IS
VERY UNCERTAIN SO WE WILL KEEP
IN TOUCH WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AS WE ARE CONSTANTLY REFINING.
OUR ESTIMATES- AND AS WE GET
MORE DETAIL- FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE WILL MAKE SURE TO
INCORPORATE THAT AS WELL. I
SHOULD MENTION THAT JUST THIS
WEEK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE WHITE HOUSE RELEASED
ADDITIONAL DETAIL AND SOME
GREATER FLEXIBILITY ON THE USES
OF THE CORONA VIRUS FOR WE
FIND. THAT THE LA- MENTIONED SO
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
INCORPORATE AS WE UPDATE OUR
ESTIMATES. THE SECOND ONE I
WANT TO MAKE IS- WITH REGARD TO
SOME THE CONTROL SECTIONS THAT
I KNOW MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I HAVE ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT.
AND THAT THE LA- MENTIONED AS
WELL. THE PURPOSE OF DRAFTING
THESE CONTROLS ACTIONS THE WAY
WE DID WAS TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND MAKING SURE.
THAT THE STATE IS MEETING AS
WELL AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
MEETING ALL THE DEADLINES AND
CONDITIONS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE USING ALL THE MONEY THAT
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WE ARE OPEN TO
FEEDBACK ON HOW TO REFINE THIS
CONTROL SECTIONS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO THAT
CONSISTENT WITH NOTIFICATION
AND ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- WHILE BALANCING
THAT AGAINST THE NEED TO.
ENSURE THAT IS A LITTLE OF
THOSE DOLLARS ARE REVERTED BACK
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR
NOT MEETING THE CONDITIONS THAT
WERE ALLOCATED. AS THE LA-
MENTIONED- BASED ON FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE RECEIVED WE'VE
ALREADY UPDATED LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ON INCLUDING A TEN DAY
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION.
REQUIREMENTS INTO SOME OF THAT
CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE.
SIMILAR THOUGHT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE TRIGGER. THE PURPOSE OF
THE TRIGGER IS AS WE KNOW AND
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING IN THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS. WITH ALL OF
YOU. THE NAY REVISION AB
REFLECTS AND BASS CUTS. IN THE
BUDGET IN ADDITION TO PULLING
BACK AND WITHDRAWING THE
EXPANSIONS THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN JANUARY. THESE CUTS
ARE VERY PAINFUL THEY AFFECT
JUST ABOUT EVERY PROGRAM. AND
SO WE'VE BUILT IN A TRIGGER
WHERE IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES A CERTAIN OUT
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. ALL THOSE CUTS CAN BE
RESTORED AND THEY WOULD AFFECT
ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS. BUT AS
MENTIONED WE ARE. HAPPY TO
LISTEN TO FEEDBACK WHEN IT
COMES TO ADDITIONAL IDEAS ON
HOW TO SET UP THAT TRIGGER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
MAXIMIZING BE USED. A FEDERAL
FUNDING AND AVOIDING THE IS
CUTS THAT UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. WOULD OTHERWISE GOING
TO A FACT ON LIFE FIRST IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT. OF
A BALANCED BUDGET. THE FINAL
POINT I'LL MAKE IS I KNOW AND
THE NEW KNOWS THAT THERE ARE
PAN A LOT OF. ON THE- CAN.
RESERVE IN THE MAY REVISION- WE
HAVE PUT OUT WHAT WE EXPECT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
EXPENDITURES WILL BE- BUT THE
TRUTH IS THAT THIS EMERGENCY IS
ONGOING AND WHILE YOU KNOW
TRENDS AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
MENTIONED- HAVE BEEN GETTING A
LITTLE BIT BETTER IN THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS AND WEEKS. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THE SUMMER AND THE FALL AND SO
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO DO. IS IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS BILL DIDN'T
BUILDING A CONTINGENCY SO THAT
THEY IF THERE IS A HOSPITAL
EARCH OR A RESURGENCE IN THE
PANDEMIC. IN THE FALL
ESPECIALLY THE LEGISLATURE IS
OUT OF SESSION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE STATE HAS
THE ABILITY TO ACT. I THINK- WE
ALL KNOW FROM SEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD- THAT ACTING WHEN IT
COMES THIS PANDEMIC. IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS OR EVEN DAYS.
COMPARED TO WINE ESTATE OR OUR
COUNTRY MAY HAVE ACTED. COULD
LITERALLY COUNT FOR HUNDREDS OR
THOUSANDS OF LIVES SAVED. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO MAXIMIZE
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THROUGH THE SUMMER
THROUGH THE FALL IN TERMS OF
HOW THE X. EXPENDITURES ARE
BEING MADE. BUT GIVEN THAT WE
DO NOT KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING
TO GO. WE DO ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY. SHOULD THE
PANDEMIC RETURNED TO HIGHER
LEVELS ARE EVEN HIGHER LEVELS
THAN WE HAVE SEEN UP TO THIS
POINT. SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
KEEP MY COMMENTS VERY BRIEF I
KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES
TO DISCUSS AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
FREEZE WHEN IT AGAIN. DO YOU
HAVE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR BROUGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR THE LA-
AND THEN OTHER MAJOR MY
QUESTIONS WILL BE FOR THE DEAL
F. SO TO THE LA- BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE LAUGHED SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO AND I WANTED TO
RECESS WE PASSED SB EIGHTY NINE
WHICH- INCLUDED THE SECTION
THIRTY SIX. NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY APPROPRIATIONS
AUTHORITY- MY QUESTION TO THE
LA- IS A DO YOU FEEL THAT THE
NOTIFICATIONS PROVIDED BY THE
DEAL F. HAVE MET THE LETTER AND
THE SPIRIT. OF THE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS IN THAT SETION
AND- WHAT COULD HAVE DONE BEEN
DONE BETTER BY THE DEAL F. TO
KEEP THE LEGISLATURE INFORMED
OF WHAT WAS GOING ON. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YOUR OKAY YES- OKAY
THANK YOU- YES I WILL I GUESS
ALL MAKE JUST A COUPLE OF
POINTS- THE FIRST IS THAT. YOU
KNOW. IN A IN A VARIETY OF
CASES PROBABLY MORE INFORMATION
CERTAINLY COULD HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED- I THINK THAT ONE
ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS ANDREA WHAT WHERE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION MADE AN
INITIAL TRANSFER OF ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO JURY-
FROM THE ASSET FOR YOU- WITH-
LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION JUST
GENERALLY THAT THE THAT THE-
TRANSFER WAS HAPPENING IN WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
ABOUT HOW THOSE MONIES WERE
GOING TO BE SPENT AND WE WOULD
REALLYEXPECTED AFTER THAT
POINT THAT. THAT THERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
FORTHCOMING ABOUT SPECIFICALLY
WHICH DEPARTMENTS WERE
RECEIVING THE MONEY AND
SPECIFICALLY WHICH ACTIVITIES
WERE GOING TO BE. THE MONEY WAS
GOING TO BE USED FOR- BUT WERE
QUITE SURPRISED WHEN WE DID NOT
RECEIVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION AND SO- YES I THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME EXAMPLES
OF- OF OUT OF A LACK OF
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU AND
THEN- FOR THE DEAL F. JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT- BECAUSE
THAT'S ONE OF THE- POINTS THAT
I BEEN FRUSTRATED ABOUT. A TWO
IS THE DISASTER RESPONSE
REGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT- WE
HAVE REPEATEDLY ASKED FOR
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE
ACCOUNTING OF WHAT EXPENDITURES
HAVE BEEN MADE OUT OF THREE OH-
AND STILL HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED THAT AND I'M WONDERING
WHY. THE DEAL F. IS DRAGGING
THEIR FEET ON THAT BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE I MEAN IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT. AT THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. THE WE HAVE CONCURRED
IN- AND EVERY- NEARLY EVERY
EXPENDITURE REQUESTED THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MADE BUT THAT
THE POINT OF CONTENTION HAS
BEEN THAT WE FEEL LIKE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN FIRST OF ALL
NOTIFIED AHEAD OF TIME AND
SECOND WILL PROVIDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION. TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION WHEN
CONCURRENT WITH THESE REQUESTS
SO TO THE DEAL AFTER A WHY HAS
THE TRIO- INFORMATION WE'VE
REQUESTED NOT BEEN PROVIDED. SO
I'LL COME A VERY BRIEFLY AND
THEN I MAY TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT TO RESET CALIBER.
AS WELL- WE DID PROVIDE
NOTIFICATION YOU KNOW FOR THE
TRIO I TRANSFERS AND THEN IN
THE LETTER. THAT WE SENT OUT
YESTERDAY WE SAW IN TERMS OF
ALL THE- EXPENDITURES TO DATE
AS WELL AS THE PROJECTED
EXPENDITURES. PROVIDE CLEAR
FINE DETAIL ON WHERE WE EXPECT
THOSE TO GO OUT AND FROM WHICH
ACCOUNTS YOU KNOW WHY WE ARE
DIRECTING. FUNDING THE WAY IT'S
BEING DIRECTED BUT LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO RESET TO TALK ABOUT
THE REAL EXPENDITURES IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL. HEY
GOOD MORNING THERESA COLOR WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE.
AS THIS. PANDEMIC HAS
PROGRESSED AND THE FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS HAVE BEEN MADE WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO EVOLVE AS
WELL AND I JUST OUR
NOTIFICATIONSONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE DONE IN RESPONSE TO
THEIR REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IS THAT POSTING ON
OUR WEBSITE OF THE ALLOCATIONS
NOT ONLY FOR CONTROLS SECTION
THIRTY SIX BUT AS WELL AS THE
TO REAL ALLOCATIONS- AND THE
TOTAL TO ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS REFERENCED
EARLIER IS ALSO POSTED AND BY
DEPARTMENT AND BY PURPOSE ON
OUR WEBSITE SO WE HAVE-
ATTEMPTED TO TRY AND BE
RESPONSIVE AND ALSO JUST IN. IN
LIGHT OF THE REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WITH
REGARD TO THESE EXPENDITURES
OKAY SO TO SUMMARIZE WELL WORSE
YOU'RE HEARING US SAY WE DON'T
THINK THAT WE'VE GOT THE
INFORMATION THAT WE ASK FOR AND
YOU'RE SAYING YES WE PROVIDED
ISSUES SO THERE'S A CONFLICT
SOMEWHERE IN THERE AND YOU KNOW
WE CAN WE CAN RESOLVE THIS
OFFLINE BUT THIS IS THE LATEST
IN A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR- FROM
THE DEAL F. AND IN RESPONSE TO
INCREASE FROM THE LEGISLATURE
THAT I THINK NEEDS TO STOP IF
E'RE GOING TO. HAVE A REAL
TRUSTED WITH FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS- YEAH AND I
THOUGHT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT-
WHEN WE ASK FOR INFORMATION
THAT THAT- THE DO YOU EVER
CONSIDER BEING A BIT MORE
FORTHCOMING ABOUT PROVIDING IT
BECAUSE WE DON'T FEEL LIKE-
THAT RESPONSIVENESS HAS BEEN
THERE. I WANT TO ASK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT. THE A POINT THAT THE
LA- RACIST REGARDING THE-
BUDGET CONTROL SECTION
REGARDING THE FEDERAL TRIGGERS.
AND IT WAS A QUESTION THAT- THE
LA- ASKED THAT I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANSWER TO YET WHICH IS IT I
YOU'VE GOT THESE TRIGGERS
AUTOMATICALLY SET TO OCCUR. ON
LAST APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID TO THE
STATE SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENS IF. SOMETHING LESS THAN
THAT IS RECEIVE WHAT HAPPENS IF
IT'S THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS I
MEAN ARE ALL OF THOSE CAUGHT
CUTS MADE- PROPORTIONATELY TO
THE AMOUNT THAT COMES IN FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS IT A
BINARY THING WHERE THEY'RE
EITHER ALL MADE OR THEY'RE NOT
MADE WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING ON
THIS. YES LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
ON THIS THE WAY THE CONTROL
SECTION IS DRAFTED RIGHT NOW ON
THE ENTIRE APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS AT
LEAST THAT AMOUNT- WOULD HAVE
TO. BE RECEIVED FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO OFFSET
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES IN
ORDER FOR THOSE CUTS TO BE
RESTORED ACROSS THE BOARD. SO
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY- IF WE ULTIMATELY WILL
RECEIVE LESS THAN THAT AMOUNT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OVER THE COMING YEAR. OR IF WE
RECEIVE NOTHING ADDITIONAL
CONGRESS DOES NOT PASS.
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION- THOSE
CUTS WOULD NOT BE RESTORED- AND
THEN WHEN IT COMES TO. WELL
THAT ON. FEWER THAN FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY
MONEY HOW WOULD IT BE USED ON
THAT COULD BE A COMBINATION
ARE. THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATING IT PER USUAL
PROCESSES- THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS A RELATED PROCESSES
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR- AS
WELL AS ADDITIONALLY- ANY-
COVERT NINETEEN. EMERGENCY COST
TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT FEDERAL
FUNDS. ARE ALLOCATED FOR THAT
REASON OR THEY FIT UNDER
CONTROL SECTION ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE. OKAY SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
DIVISION AT THIS POINT THAT
IT'S A BINARY PROCESS EITHER.
THE AMOUNT PROVIDED IS MORE
THAN FOURTEEN BILLION OR DOES
NOT. THAT'S CORRECT IF IT'S- A
WASTE FOURTEEN BILLION THERE IS
NO ATOM NOT AUTOMATIC
RESTORATION- FOR ANY OF THOSE
PROGRAMS IN THE CHARTER.
ALRIGHT SO I'M SURE THAT THERE
WILL BE A- SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DISCUSSING HERE IN
THE NEXT- COMING WEEKS- BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THERE HAS TO BE
SOME KIND OF PROVISION MADE.
FOR IF THAT FOR FULL FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS DOESN'T COME
IN- IN A AND A AND ALSO
THINKING DONE ABOUT- WHICH OF
THOSE CUTS WOULD BE MADE WHICH
WOULD NOT. AT ALL. LASTLY AT I
APOLOGIZE IF THIS IS GETTING
INTO THE WEEDS A LITTLE BIT
BUT- I WANT TO POINT OUT
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
DOING AND IT'S- ROUND OF CUTS
TRIGGERED BY- THIS FEDERAL AID.
OR THE LACK THEREOF AND THAT IS
THE CLOSURE OF VETERANS HOMES-
YOU KNOW MOST. WERE BROADLY
BASED A CERTAIN PERSON IN THIS
PROGRAM A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE
FOR THAT PROGRAM BUT THIS WAS A
YOU KNOW THE CLOSURE OF AN
ENTIRE. DISPENSED PARTICULARLY
WANTED MY DISTRICT IN BARSTOW
AND I'M WONDERING WHY. THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS LIKE
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE. CUT TO
BE MADE UGH YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THIS IS ONE OF MOST
VULNERABLE SEGMENTS OF OUR
POPULATION. YES SO THE BOND
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT
BACK WITH OUR STAFF. WERE FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON THOSE ISSUES
YOU KNOW TODAY WE ONLY HAVE THE
STAFF THAT ARE FOCUSED MORE
BROADLY ON THE CONTROL
SECTIONS. AND THE FEDERAL FUNDS
AND EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES BUT
I WILL GET BACK TO YOU I WILL
SAY AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW
THIS. AS WELL AS ANYBODY OUT
ALL OF THE WISCONSIN THE
TRIGGER- ARE THE CUTS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO MAKE A
LEAST YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
WASN'T HAPPY ABOUT. WITHDRAWING
EXPANSION AND IS. SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE IN THE
BUDGET BACK IN PARTICULAR
THAT'S THE REASON THAT THEY'RE
IN THIS TIGER. THESE ARE THE
POTS- THAT WE ARE REALLY HOPING
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR BECAUSE- AS THE GOVERNOR
SAID IN HIS NAY REVISION
CROSSTALK FRIEND STAY BREAK HIS
HEART. SO THAT'S WHY THEY'RE IN
THE TRIGGER. OKAY THANK YOU YOU
GOT AYE I THINK WE ALL SHARE.
IN THE FEELING THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO MAKE ANY OF THESE CUTS.
BUT YOUKNOW OBVIOUSLY IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE THE- IN
ROOM AND TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT'S WE NEED TO BE. NEED TO
BE MADE. I AND BALANCE THE
BUDGET. THE SO THERE ARE I
DON'T. IT WOULD BE RESPOND TO
CUT. AND I'M SURE YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT. YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE ANSWER. THE QUESTION. THANK
YOU FOR. BURKE WITH. PROPER OF
FINANCE HAVE. HEAVY COTTON. HOW
YOU'RE GONNA CHANGE THE-
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN YOUR
OFFICE IN THE LEGISLATURE. GET
GIVEN. THAT WE NOW HAVE. A FEW
FEW MONTHS OF COMMUNICATION
THIS WAY AND AGAIN. JUST TO
REITERATE WHAT MY MIND IF I
SHARE- OUR VICE CHAIR SAID IS
THAT THAT. COMMUNICATION REALLY
HASN'T BEEN ADEQUATE AS FAR
FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW. YES A
WE WANNA. BE AS ENGAGED AND
COMMUNICATE AS MUCH WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS POSSIBLE I'D
DEFINITELY HEARING THE FEEDBACK
AND WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
TO SHARE THAT WITH. COLLEAGUES
OVER HERE AND I THINK WHEN IT
COMES MORE SPECIFICALLY TO THE
NUTS AND BOLTS OF SOME OF THESE
CONTROL SECTIONS ARE OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT WERE
DISCUSSING- WAYS IN WHICH WE
CAN STRENGTHEN THE NOTIFICATION
PROCESS. AS MENTIONED- WITH
THE- FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
EXAMPLE AS THE LA- POINTED OUT
OUR NATIONAL LANGUAGE  DID NOT
HAVE LEGISLATIVE NOTIFICATION
AND WE RECOGNIZED AFTER HEARING
THAT HE THOUGHT THAT.
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT NEEDS THAT
KIND OF NOTIFICATION- INCLUDING
A TEN DAY- WAITING PERIODS SO
WE INCLUDE. INCLUDED THAT AND
ARE REVISED AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
IMPROVE OUR COMMUNICATION.
THANK YOU BUT JUST BE CLEAR.
THE WAIT LATEST LEGISLATIVE HAS
GONE IN THE PAST HAS BEEN.
EVERYTHING'S DONE. WHAT WERE
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
ANNOUNCING THIS AND- WE'RE
GIVING YOU TEN MINUTES ADVANCE
NOTICE OF WHICH THE OFTENTIMES
THE ADVANCE NOTICE FROM YOUR
DIVISION WOULD GO TO SAY OUR
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF BUT
I'M STILL WATCHING TV TO GET MY
NOTIFICATION. SO IT BET BIG THE
QUESTION WHAT'S THE POINT OF A
LEGISLATURE IF WE'RE LIKE THE
PUBLIC WATCHING TV TO GET
INFORMATION DOESN'T FEEL VERY
DEMOCRATIC TO ME. SO I MISSED
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS ON.
THE ISSUE O THE PPP AND THE
AND THE MASK SO I GUESS THE BIG
OVERALL ONE BEFORE I GET TOO
SPECIFIC PART OF THE BUDGET AND
A SECTOR THAT THAT NEEDS THIS
PROTECTION. IS THE WHOLE-
CONTRACT IN THE ONE BILLION AND
I THINK WE GOT OVER THAT OVER
AND OVER AND OVER BUT- IF IT
LEADS TO THAT QUESTION IS THAT
THE REASON THAT THE GOVERNOR
DEAD AS AS CHAIRMAN TING SAID
GO OUT AND ANNOUNCE THIS AND WE
HEARD ABOUT IT ON. ON THE
NATIONAL TV SHOW BUT IT IS WHAT
IT IS WAS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
IN TO MAKE A MAJOR BOOK
PURCHASING THAT FELL APART WHEN
WE ARE IS- SCAMMERS THAT PUT
TOGETHER AN INDUSTRY THREE DAYS
BEFORE AND WIRED MONEY IT
SOUNDS LIKE A- CRAZY TV MOVIE.
MADE FOR TV MOVIE BUT
NONETHELESS WE DIDN'T LOSE OUT
A SIGNIFICANT WAY WOULD BE
PROTECTED TAXPAYERS BUT A BEGS
THE QUESTION WHERE ARE WE NOW
ON THESE MASKS- WHERE WE
OPENING OUR ECONOMY. WE'RE
OPENING- IS THE SENSE OF
WORKERS THAN THE DEFINITION
THAT EXPANDED EXPONENTIALLY BY
THESE COUNTY ORDERS RIGHTFULLY
SO- THERE COULD BE A SECOND
WAVE AS AS WE AS WE NOW WE HOPE
NOT SO. DEALS ARE AS WE WRAP
AND I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES IS AS- THEN I IT'S-
CERTAIN SHIN SO PACKED. AFTER
YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN US PLAY. YES
I SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED THE
START ADDITION TO A SMALL
NUMBER OF MY TO OF FINANCE HE
WE ALSO. TINA CAR THEY GET THE
AT WE ASKED AS WELL AS RIGHT
SELMA. AS WELL AS MORE
COMMITTED FROM AGE SO WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE OPERATE
OPERATIONAL QUESTIONS THERE ON
HAND SO LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
T. TO CURRY FROM YES RIGHT NOW.
GOOD MORNING. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- WHERE WE ARE ON THE
MASTER STARES AT TWO DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS THAT WERE PART OF THE
BID CONTRACT- AS YOU MENTIONED
THIS IS BEEN DISCUSSED AND IN
PRIOR ON PRIOR HEARINGS WE HAVE
AT THE END NINETY FIVE AS WELL
AS THE SURGICAL THE SURGICAL
MASKS WE ARE RECEIVING THOSE
SUPPLY OR DISTRIBUTING THOSE
SUPPLY- AS WE SPEAK AND HAVE
BEEN FOR THE PAST- WELL IT'S A
NEGATIVE EVENT THAT REALLY. AND
BASED ON THE IDEA TRACK SADDAM
AT LADY. THE NINTH HOUSE TO.
FOR AND NINETY FIVE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR CONTRACT WAS WAS
DELAYED- SO THAT WE'RE WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC THAT PROCESS IS
STILL ONGOING BUT WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC THAT- THAT THAT'S
MOVING ALONG. AND WE DON'T HAVE
THE FINAL- FINAL AT AND
CERTIFICATION YET BUT WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC THAT THAT'S GOING TO
BECOME COMING ALONG IN THE
TIMELINE THAT. OTHER TELL YOUR
POINT. BUT THE REAL US THAT
UNKNOWN NATURE OF ANY TYPE OF
RESURGENCE OR OR ADDITIONAL
CASES WE WANT TO BE PREPARED
FOR THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE IS
PREPARED FOR THAT. AND WE ARE
HAVE A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THE SUPPLY CHAIN STILL AS THIS
IS A NATIONAL AND WORLDWIDE
EPIDEMIC SO. ON WE HOPE TO SEE
WELL THOSE WERE PUSHED OUT. FOR
THIRTY DAYS WE HOPE TO NOW
START SEEING THOSE EARLY NEXT
MONTH WITH THE CERTIFICATIONS
IN PLACE AND WILL CERTAINLY
EVERYONE UPDATE ON UP. SO
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN IN PLAIN ENGLISH AS
FAR AS- A BACKUP PLAN. WE'RE
WE'RE COUNTING ON ON THIS- WE
HAD SOME UNCERTAINTY OUT OF THE
GATE AND WHAT LEADS US TO
BELIEVE THAT. IT'S GOING TO BE
AT A DONE DEAL GOING FORWARD
AND WHAT'S OUR PLAN B. FOR THIS
FOR THE AND NINETY FIVE MASKS.
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT AS A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ABSOLUTELY-
TO GREAT POINT- A FEW THINGS
THAT WE HAVE IN. PLACE AS A
BACK UP IT WAS WORKING TO ORDER
THE NINETY FIVE ASKED NOT TO-
EXPEND FUNDS UNLESS WE NEED
THEM BUT WE ARE STILL TRYING TO
PUSH OTHER SORTS OF THE-
INTERNET SUPPLY CHAINS OPEN UP.
AND THE OTHER THING IS WE'RE
LEVERAGING TO THE MAXIMUM
EXTENT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE. THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
STOCKPILE WE KNOW THAT WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
OR OTHER STATES NEEDS. THAT
THEY ARE SO- AT IT EXECUTED
SOME NEW PROGRAMS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC INCLUDING SOMETHING
ABOUT CREATION ERROR PAGE WHICH
WAS TO HELP THE FLYER SUPPLY.
THE HOSPITALS IN THAT. QUOTE
FIVE AND WE KNOW IT'S- OUR A
KEY AREAS IN OUR HOT PULLS ARE
RECEIVING SUPPLIES THROUGH
THEIR- SUPPLY. EIGHT I'M IN
SELECT. THEY WERE HEADING AND
THE OTHER. THE CONTINGENCY WE
HAVE IN PLACE IS WE CALL THEM I
TELL. YOU CAN TO. UNITS WE HAVE
TWO OF. IN CAL. THEY CAN-
DEACON IN EIGHT. FIVE PASSED UP
TO CAL AT. AND WE HAVE A FORTY
OR FIVE HUNDRED DIFFERENT
HOSPITALS THAT ARE SIGNED UP
FOR THAT AND WE ARE ACTIVELY
PUSHING THAT'S TRUE THAT IS NOT
IDEAL BUT IT IS A ANOTHER
CAPABILITY THAT WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE AND TO CALIFORNIA. SO ALL
THAT TO SAY IS WE DO HAVE-
OTHER OTHER- CAPABILITIES THAT
WE'VE AND LISTED AND ADDITION
TO LEVERAGING TO THE MAXIMUM
EXTENT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS PUT INTO PLACE
TO ENSURE. THAT THERE IS SOME
SUPPLY THESE RESOURCES COMING
IN TO THE PLACES THAT NEED THEM.
OKAY TWO MORE ISSUES I WANT TO
WHEN A PROBE.A ONE THIS IS OUR
OVERSIGHT HEARING AND- AS
CHAIRMAN TING SAID IT'S ABOUT
GOING FOR BUT ALSO LOOKING BACK
TO LEARN FROM. LEARN FROM THIS
IN IN THE EVENT THAT WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THIS TERRIBLE
SITUATION AGAIN. AND WHEN WE
MET A FEW WEEKS AGO IT HAS COME
TO LIGHT THE DETAILS OF THIS
BILL ARE CONTRACT AND THAT. THE
THIRD FOUR HAVE BILLION DOLLARS
WAS WHY. TO THE- I KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT IT
WE HAD ANOTHER ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. THE ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMUNITY THINK IT'S CALLED HOW
TO HEARING A COUPLE WEEKS ON ON
THIS I WASN'T THERE I DON'T
THINK MADE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH THEIR- SO MAYBE
YOU CAN ENLIGHTEN US ON. YOU
KNOW THE LESSONS LEARNED AND
WHAT WE WILL DO DIFFERENT-
BECAUSE IT IS SHOCKING. WHAT%
HAPPENED WHAT TRANSPIRED- IT'S
LITERALLY IS. SOMETHING THAT IS
AT FICTION TYPE OF A THING- AND
SO IF YOU CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND. WHAT WE ARE DOING
DIFFERENT WELL AS RECALL NOTED.
IS A MAY THE STATE IN FINE OUT
ON THE BANKS THE SOFT HEY THIS
DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT. SENDING
TAPPED A BILLION DOLLARS TO A
COMPANY THAT WAS CREATED THREE
DAYS AGO. SO WHAT DO WE HAVE
PLAYED. IN OUR NEXT AROUND
REGIS IS THAT SOMETHING THIS.
ANY AND SOME IS THERE ARE
ABSOLUTELY LET LEARN IN A IN
THIS ERA SO AND WE DID DISCUSS
THAT AT THAT THE HEARING YOU
MEANT IT WAS THAT WAS ITWAS
PRETTY ON THIS TOPIC SO WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THAT IS GOING
FORWARD WE HAVE A STEP. SO WHAT
THAT MEANS IS WE'RE GETTING A
LOT OF. INTERESTED PARTIES THAT
WANT TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE P. P.
E. SOLUTION WHETHER IT'S TO FOR
SALE OR FOR DONATIONS. AND
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A PORTAL FOR
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
VETTING PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN
EFFICIENTLY- TAKEN THOSE OFFERS
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW KIND OF
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THERE AND
WHAT'S NOT THERE. AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PUSHING JUST
THOSE THINGS THAT WE FEEL ARE
VALID AND ARE USEFUL FOR THE
STATE CALIFORNIA'S. INTO THE
POLITICAL WORK PERMIT SYSTEM SO
THAT'S ONE ASPECT THAT'S
AVAILABLE ON OUT THROUGH THE
COVERED NINETEEN. WEBSITE THE
I'M OTHER HOME. AS WE- AND THIS
IS GOING. ALL OF COUNTRY AND
INCLUDING HEARING BUT FOR NOW
IS THAT WE HAVE ENTITIES.
PROMISES THAT WOULD PUSH ANSWER
NOT. AND THEY WERE NOT MET. AND
WE NEED TO YOU KNOW NOT BE
SPENDING TIME ON THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE NOT GOING TO. TO AT
PAN OUT OR OR PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED- SO AND
SOME OF THOSE HAVE BEEN-
SUSPECTED THAT- ARE FRAUDULENT-
OR CRIMINAL AND SO WE HAVE
ENGAGE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
INVESTIGATE AND TO PURSUE-
ANYTHING THAT WE FEEL THAT THAT
FALLS INTO THAT AREA AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE FOLLOWING
UP ON THOSE AS WELL SO- LOTS
MEMBER ADAM AT PROCESSES IN
PLACE AND SAFEGUARDS TO BE
THERE ON ARE BETTING. BUT
AGAIN- BEING ABLE TO. ABBY IF
XIN AN ACT QUICKLY- AND- YOU
GET THE PLOT. NEED PROTECT THAT
THAT SALUTE. AND MARK THAT WE
HAVE AN DEFINITELY LEARNING FOR
EXPERIENCE IS THE LEARNING FROM
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN OTHER STATES
AND AROUND THE WORLD IT REALLY
HAS BEEN UNPRECEDENTED-
LEARNING ABOUT SUPPLY CHAIN
AND- JUST INCREDIBLE
COMPETITION FOR THIS SCARCE
RESOURCE AND SO- WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE LEARNED FROM THAT AND ARE
INVOLVING AND GOING FORWARD
WELL. I WILL MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
WELL NEEDLESS TO SAY THE FACT
THAT WE WERE PARTIALLY DUE TO
NEARLY TOTALLY DUPED IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND I THINK THE
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
EVERYBODY WATCHING IS- IS UP
AGAINST THAT NEARLY OF EXCEL. I
WITH WILL WE TAKE THAT'S THE
EFFORT TO I. TECH DOES GOING
FORWARD GOING BACK THE TO THE
TO THE HOLD UP FROM- I FORGET
AGENCY CALLED WHAT'S IN ITS
THE- THE CERTIFICATION THE
OCEARCH SAID. DIOS NILES SO.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT WAS
IMMINENT THREE OR FOUR WEEKS
AGO AND IT'S IS- GETTING LATER
IN THE MONTH OF MAY IT WAS
EARLY MAY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE.
TODAY TOMORROW TYPE OF A THING
SO WHAT'S GOING ON A WHAT'S THE
HOLD UP NOW ON MAY TWENTY LOWER.
WE'RE TALKING TO NIASSE
REGULARLY ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THIS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE ARE
EXTREMELY INTERESTED IN THE IN
THE TIME LINE AS WELL SO. BUT I
CAN'T SAY AS WERE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND- RIGHT NOW
EVERYTHING IS MOVING FORWARD AS
IT AS EXPECTED ON THE NEW
TIMELINE AND HOPEFULLY WE WILL.
HAVE MORE TO- TO SHARE- IN THE
COMING DAYS ON THE STATUS OF
THAT BUT I CAN'T I CAN'T SAY
THAT WE ARE VERY VERY CLOSE
CONTACT WITH AN AYE AUSTIN
KEEPING TABS ON. THIS IN YEAH
FUNDING FOR AT AT TIMELY
RESOLUTION. ALL RIGHT AND THEN
LASTLY FOR THE- APPLICATION OF
THESE PROTECTIVE- THIS
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR SOME
OF OUR INDUSTRIES OF COURSE-
DOCTOR RAMBLE OUT TALKING
GREAT. DETAIL ABOUT THE HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY BUT THERE'S OTHER
ESSENTIAL FACT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND INDUSTRIES ONE IS
THE CHILD CARE TO ST SCHOOLS-
BEEN OPEN FOR HIS. FIRST ART
FOR EXAMPLE ARE COUNTY WERE AND
ARE AT THE STAGE TO OUR COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ISSUED.
GUIDANCE THIS WEEK TO RE OPEN
MORE CHILD CARE CENTERS AND
THIS WAS IS A HUGE NEED IN OUR
APRIL HEARING. FINANCE
MENTIONED THAT THEY WOULD BE
COMING SHORTLY TO- TO SCHOOLS
IN CHILD CARE FACILITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND TO UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT HASN'T. MATERIALIZED
WHAT'S THE DEAL THAT IS THAT
BECAUSE OUR WAY FOR THIS BIG
ORDER OR IS IT ARE THERE TWO
SEPARATE THINGS GOING ON HERE
WELL THERE'S IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS SEC-
JEKYLL MASS LIKE. WEARING YOU
HAVE A SUPPLY OF THOSE AND AS A
MAN COMING IN THROUGH THE- V.
WHY DO A CONTRACT OR PART OF
THE BEAGLE DE CONTRACT AS WELL
AS OTHER. BE A MAN. WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. PROCESS
WHICH LED IS AS YOU. OUT HERE
WAS A LARGE THAT. HAD IN THE
LAST IN THE WEEK THAT AND-
CHILD AT THE IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
SOMEWHERE IN. IN THAT NEIGHBOR
OF FIVE. MASS YOU KNOW OR TAKE
I HAVE TO GET BACK IN THE
DETAILS ON EXACTLY WHAT THE
BREAKDOWN. THE TUBES OF THOSE
BUT WE ARE WORK ON THOSE WITH
HE JUST TREES OUTSIDE OF HEALTH
CARE THAT NEED THE- PROTECTIVE
THESE THE MAP IN ORDER TO
REOPEN IN ORDER TO OPERATE
SAFELY. AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
NON HEALTH. SERVICES THAT WE
ARE WORKING CHEAPER SOME. OF
THE NEEDS. THAT COINCIDES WITH
THE RE OPENING AND THE SAFE
OPERATION OF THESE FACILITIES
BUT HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
SPECIFICS ON CHILD CARE WITH
YOU AND WHERE THAT'S GONNA.
COURSE ANY STANDING NEEDS THAT
WE HAVE NOT HEARD ABOUT OR NOT
ADDRESS THAT WE- I'D LIKE TO
HEAR THE DETAILS OF THAT TOO SO
THAT WE CAN. GET THEM ALL THE-
AS FAR YOU KNOW THE GUY.
MONTEREY BASIS IS A- SOME WAY
REAL ERICA IN BALANCING THE
ECONOMY VERSUS PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND A BIG PART OF THAT IS HOW
PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK AND-
PART OF THAT IS. SCHOOLS AND
CARE FOR THE GREAT. SURE SO NOT
ONLY AS AN OF FOR OUR ECONOMY
BUT THAT SANITY FOR A LOT OF
PARENTS OUT THERE FRANKLY A LOT
OF MOTHERS WHO ARE. TRYING TO
BACK- BURKE IN TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE REALITY OF. BEING A
WHOLE SCHOOL TEACHER AND- AS
WELL AS BEING A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER AND IF THEY'RE IF
THEY'RE JOBS OPENING BACK UP
AND GO BACK TO WORK HOW DOES
THAT WORK IF THEY DON'T HAVE.
OTHER PIECE TO MAKE TO MAKE A
FAMILY WHAT TO DO WITH THEIR
KIDS. AND SO. DO WE THINK THAT
WE HAVE THE ADEQUATE RESOURCES
OUT THERE. TO OPEN UP SCHOOLS
AND CHILDCARE CENTERS DO WE
THINK THAT WE HAVE THEIR THEIR
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
PROTECTIVE GEAR AND- AND THINGS
IN PLACE TO MAKE IT WORK FOR
OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE THAT'S- A
BIG PART OF. GETTING THE RIGHT
BACK AT. TEN PEOPLE GO BACK TO
WORK. THAT DON'T HAVE THE OTHER
ELEMENT GOING AT THE SAME TIME.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ALL SPEAK TO THAT- MASKS PART
OF IT OF COURSE IS A LOT OF
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS WITH
SCHOOL RE OPENING I KNOW THAT
WERE ACTIVELY IN THE STATE ARE
WORKING- WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ON GUIDANCE AROUND RE
OPENING THAT INVOLVES A LOT OF
THINGS BUT IN TERMS OF THE- OF
THE MASKS AND WEARE WORKING-
WITH THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND LOTS OF
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT. WE HAVE
PROVIDED- THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
FOR EXAMPLE WOULD SERVICE- THE
DAY CARE THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH SCHOOLS SO THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE OPEN NOW AND WE HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTING WITH THE ACT
WITH THE I. P. P. E. IN THE-
AND- I. CERTAINLY FOR. PRESENT
TIMING EVERY. LOOKS WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT NEED MIGHT
BE- IN A COUPLE IT AGAIN JUST
TO GO BACK ITS TERMS OF THE
STATE'S ROLE IN PROVIDING PP
EVEN WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTING. DURING THIS
TIME OF. URGENCY WHICH INCLUDES
BUT THE RESPONSE TO KOBE BUT
ALSO THE RE OPENING. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE SUPPLIES ARE VERY HARD
TO GET IN BALK ACROSS THE BOARD
STILL. SO WE'RE ALSO. SEEING
THAT IT DISSIPATING WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO SUPPORT THAT
DIRECTLY. ALSO KIND OF KEEPING
AN EYE ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
SEEING HOW HOW HOW THAT GOES IS
THAT OF ALL IS OVER TIME.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT'S GOIN YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT- AT FINANCIAL
IF THE FINANCIAL SITUATION AND
IS. THERE THEN THERE BE A BILL
IF PURCHASED AGAIN SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT. TOP WHAT WE DO
NOT. TO SUPPORT RE OPENING AT.
LET'S SEE AN THEN WE MIGHT.
THAT YOU SUPPORT EFFICIENT
PROCUREMENT. WHEN IT TO THAT
POINT. OUT OKAY. SO THAT THAT
CAN HAPPEN. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S AN ONGOING ISSUE AND
THAT IF WE DON'T OBVIOUSLY- GET
A RIGHT HAVE THE RIGHT SUPPORTS
IT'S GOT TO BE VERY VERY
CHALLENGING TO RE OPEN OUR
ECONOMY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MCCARTY SO I'M JUST JUST A
QUICK FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR- SO CAN YOU CAN
YOU WALK US THROUGH A WIDE THEY
KEY AND NINETY FIVE MASS FROM
B. Y. DE WERE NOT APPROVED IN
THE SPECIFIC REASONS FOR NOT
APPROVAL. AND IT WAS SET IN
NINETY FIVE NOT A QUé NOT IN
NINETY FIVE THAT WE- JUST TO
CLARIFY THAT- THAT POINT SO OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
ACTUAL PRODUCT QUALITY WENT
THROUGH TESTING YEAH- YEAH SO
THAT PART WAS OF WAS WAS-
IMPORTING TO US WAS NOT THE
ISSUE THE ISSUE CAME BACK AT
THE DOOR HEY WHAT. WAS ON. AT
THE PAPER WORK IN THE IN THE
CERTIFICATION IN THE FACTORY
INSPECTION SO- SAID THAT. THAT
NONETHELESS THAT IS A
CORRECTION THAT HAD TO BE MADE
AND SO THAT'S THE PART THAT-
WAS NOT COMPLETE THE FIRST TIME
AROUND THEY HAD TO BE
RECERTIFIED WITH KNOWLEDGE THAT
WE'RE NOW WORKING THROUGH.
HOPEFULLY THE FINAL STAGES OF.
IT'S SO YOU HAVE TO TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION I ASSUME THEN
GET SOMEONE FROM MY OUR SHOP TO
CHINA WHEN IS THAT WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT HAPPENING.
THAT'S ALL HAPPENING LIKE THEY
WERE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH MY
OFFICE ON A REGULAR BASIS- BE
PERHAPS NOT REALLY BUT-
DEFINITELY VERY FREQUENTLY WITH
WEEKLY THEY HAVE STAFF THAT ARE
IN. IN PLACE IN THE FACTORY IS
AS WELL AS HERE IN THE US SO
WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSE BE I'M
SURE THERE ARE UNDER THE TOP
WING. THEIR PROCESS AND THEN
THING IS HAPPENING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED- YOU KNOW
SO WE'RE- SO THEY DO HAVE
ASSETS IN PLACE TO FACILITATE
THIS. ACROSS THE BOARD YOU KNOW
THIS ONE- PROJECT I IMAGINE OF.
VERY CLOSE. TO MAKE SURE THE WE
KNOW WHAT THEIR TIME I AS AS A
AFFECTS THIS PROCUREMENT BURKE
GREAT THANK YOU I'M GONNA GO TO
DOCTOR REGULAR AND THEN MR FALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- YOU
KNOW FALLING IF I MAY BE AGAIN
I'M GONNA GO IN A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION I'D I DO
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE COVE IN
RESPONSE EXPENDITURES AS WELL
AS THE NAY REVISION THAT THE
CHAIRS OUTLINED. BUT I WANT TO
HAVE A FOCUSED DISPARITIES IF I
CAN IS THIS PANDEMIC IS NOT
EQUALLY FELT AMONGST ALL
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND AS
OUR CHILDREN OUR ELDERLY AND
OUR DISABLED OR FACING THIS
DYNAMIC I WANT TO ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS IF I MAY. I WILL ASK
A TOTAL OF TWO OF THE LA AND
LOVE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LIKE STAR THE LAYOUT PLEASE.
FIRST BECOMES. IS THAT
REDUCTION WE'VE SEEN WITHIN MAY
REVISION. THAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED NOW WILL AFFECT
THESE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND MY QUESTION IS WHETHER OR
NOT THE COVERT NINETEEN.
EXPENDITURES THAT WE HAVE. HAS
BEEN FELT MOST STRONGLY AMONGST
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST HEALTH DISPARITIES
ALREADY AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINOS AND ONCE AGAIN THE
ELDERLY. SO FOR THE LA HAVE YOU
BEEN ABLE TO STUDY WHETHER THE
EXPENDITURES THAT THE STATE HAS
DIRECTED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE OR HAVE
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED THE NEEDS
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN OUR STATE.
WHAT'S UP THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULARTHAT'S NOT A QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE- INVESTIGATED IN
DETAIL BUT- WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE
A RESPONSE. THAT'S EXACTLY THE
ANSWER I WAS ACTUALLY HOPING TO
GET FROM YOU ONLY TO SHOW THAT
WE'RE PAYING ATTENTION AND THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO ARE GOING TO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS. THAT WE'RE MAKING
OUR WITH THE NOT TOWARDS
DISPARITIES IN VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT
ON. NEXT QUESTION IS FOR
FINANCE. PART OF THE
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WERE MADE IN
THE MAY REVISED TO HELP US WITH
THE COLD AND PANDEMIC WORD TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO PROP FIFTY
SIX I HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME
ADVOCATE OF USING PROP FIFTY
SIX FUND TO HELP US TO EDUCATE
TO TRAIN AND TO RETAIN OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. AS WE
KNOW NOW IS A SEVERE SHORTAGE
OF PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS IN
PARTICULAR IN REGIONS OF OUR
STATE. BUT THESE USES OF PROP
FIFTY SIX REVENUES REALLY DO
CREATE RESILIENCY AND OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. PROVIDING CARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE HEALTH CARE. FOR
EXAMPLE PROP FIFTY SIX IS USED
TO NOT ONLY HELP PATIENTS BUT
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE IN
RURAL AREAS LIKE IN MY
COMMUNITIES TO OBTAIN ACCESS
TO. HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THROUGH MEDI CAL OR FAMILY PLAN
PATENT AT A PLANNED PARENTHOOD
HEALTH CENTER THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE BUT THOSE REVENUES ALSO
HELP TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS
ADAPTATION OF. TO ONE. SO DOES
WHY NOT TELL FORECAST ABOUT THE
LONG TERM FISCAL IMPACT. OF
THAT DIVERSION OF FUNDS TO OUR
STATE AND THE FEDERAL MATCHING
FUNDS WE COULD POTENTIALLY LOSE
AS A RESULT. YES A SEVEN MEMBER
UP AYE AYE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SPECIFIC- FEDERAL FUNDS MATCH
DETAILS AND HOW THEY MATCH UP
WITH THAT PROPERTY SIX SPENDING
PLAN AST YEAR COMPARED TO WHAT
WE ARE PROPOSING. THIS YEAR WE
WILL GET BACK- AND CIRCLE UP
WITH YOUR OFFICE ON BACK I
THINK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
OVERALL VALUE OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FUNDED THAT YOU
DESCRIBED. CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AGREED
WEST AND THAT'S WHY IT WAS IN
OUR JANUARY THERE'S BUDGET.
WISE AND WE WILL BOARD WORKING
WITH. IN THE COMING WEEKS AS
WITH ALL ROUTE HOW DO WE
CONTINUE. TO HAVE THOSE
PRIORITIES WHILE. IF IT. IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME I'M TO TELL
YOU WHY I DO. AND PARENTHOOD I
GREW UP IN A VERY POOR ZIP CODE
IN FRESNO AND THE CLOSEST
CLINIC WE HAD WAS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. MY SISTER'S FIRST
JOB WAS THERE AND HOW THEY HELP
TO PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE FOR A
VAST NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS. MY
CONCERN IS THIS ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S US NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS THAT
WERE NOT ABLE TO PULL DOWN. AND
THAT HELPS US TO SUPPORT A
HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
PROVIDES CARE TO COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE AND SO I HOPE. WE CAN
WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT FUNDING TEND TO USE. IN MY
NEXT IS GOING TO BE FOR THE LA-
AND IT'S TO HELP ME WITH SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE-
I HAVE BEEN WORKING N A LINE
OF THINKING AND- REALLY DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT AS
A LEGISLATURE. A FEW YEARS AGO
I THIRD A BILL THAT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW IN AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY NINE REGARDING MEDICAL
LOSS RATIOS. AND IT'S A
PROVISION WITHIN OUR AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT TO ENSURE THAT PLANS.
ARE SPENDING OUR PREMIUMS ON
HEALTH CARE. AND IN THIS CRISIS
MY CONCERN IS THAT M. O. R. IS
RETROSPECTIVE AND REALLY LOOKS
MANY YEARS. IN THE PAST AND
DOESN'T PROVIDE US RESOURCES IN
THE MOMENT. AND SO MY QUESTION
FOR THE LA- IS TO WORK WITH MY
OFFICE REGARDING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SO THAT WE MAY
POTENTIALLY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
AVOID CLOSE OF ONE THIRD OF
PRIMARY CARE OFFICES WHICH IS.
BEING FLOATED DUE TO THIS
PANDEMIC AND THE CRISIS THAT.
WE ARE IN. SO IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT HEALTHCARE PLANS ARE
REQUIRED BY KNOCKS KEEN TO HAVE
NETWORK ADEQUACY. HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE LANGUAGE
WITHIN OUR BUDGET THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO RETAIN THOSE
RESOURCES DURING THIS CRISIS TO
SUPPORT OUR HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARAMBULA- FOR YOUR
QUESTION AGAIN- I AM NOT THE-SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT ON-
HEALTH MATTERS GIVEN SOCIAL
DISTANCING IT'S JUST ME HERE
TODAY BUT AGAIN OUR STOCK WOULD
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND I
WITH YOUR STAFF. TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT IS
REQUIRED THANK YOU AND- MISTER
CHAIR ONE FINAL QUESTION IF I
MAY. YOU KNOW MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT WE'VE SEEN
WITHIN THE REVISED ADDRESS THE
ANTICIPATED INCREASES THAT WE
EXPECT WITHIN MEDI CAL
ENROLLMENT- AND I WANTED TO
TALK IF I CAN ABOUT PART OF THE
REDUCTIONS THAT WE ARE SEEING
WITHIN BOTH. DEPARTMENT AGING
WITHIN CITY BASS WITH AN S. S.
P. AS WELL AS THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. AND
WHICH ARE OFF SAID IN A
TEMPORARY INCREASE IN THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE FOR A LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES UNDER
COVERT NINETEEN. RELATED
SPENDING NOW. BUT HOW DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION VIEW THE CASE
LOW AND SERVICES BEING PROVIDED
IN A POST CODE VISIT NINETEEN
FISCAL OUTLOOK. THE KILLER
ELITE FOR POPULAR OPTIONS WE
MIGHT NOT BE ABLE ACCESS CARE
PROVIDED IN A MORE FORMAL
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS A LONG
TERM CARE. OR A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY AND WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY HERE IS IT FEELS AS IF
THERE'S A FINAL OCCURRING.
THEREFORE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
CARE IN. MORE TRADITIONAL
SETTINGS BE- SEA BASS OR M. S.
S. P. THAT WE ARE FUNNELING
PATIENTS INTO OR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES SINCE WE
HAVE TWELVE HUNDRED SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND A
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN THOUSAND
TOTAL PATIENTS ACROSS THOSE
FACILITIES WHAT HAPPENS
POTENTIALLY POST EMMA SAYS HE'S
BASS. WHO WAS HONORING THE
SNAPS TO ONE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING ADEQUATE TO THOSE
PENSION. YES DOCTOR AND-
ALTHOUGH SPECIFIC ISSUES SO I
DON'T HAVE MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THAT HHS UNIT HERE AND FINANCE
WITH ME SO WILL HAVE TO CIRCLE
BACK WITH YOU I WILL SAY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE NAY REVISION
AND WE ALL KNOW MANY OF THESE
CUTS ARE. AND FALL THE FOCUS
WAS ON TO PREPARE A BANK AT
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY SO MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE NOW
BEFORE I CONTINUE TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAID OUT. OF
THIS CRISIS. WITHOUT TO JUMP
GROUP HAS AVERAGED TERMINATION
HOOPS IN TERMS OF THEIR
ELIGIBILITY WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE PROPOSED CUTS THAT
YOU CITED- AREN'T PAID FULL AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU TO.
WAYS. TO MINIMIZE. CORE
STEPPING BACK. THERE IS THE YOU
MAY INCLUDING UP AND I SAYS P.
RIVAS TODAY SERVICE SAID AS
WELL AS A SET OF NAY CAL SO
CALLED OPTIONAL BENEFITS ARE
ALL AIMED AT GENERAL OF DOLLARS
BUT UNDER SPECIFIC FOR THE
LONGER TERM I KNOW SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES WILL BE CIRCLING
BACK WITH YOU AND I WILL JUST
AND IF I CAN THE- YOU HAD
MENTIONED THE MEDI CAL
ESTIMATES AND- L. L. HAD DONE
AN ANALYSIS AND SIMMS THAT
YOU'RE APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS A OR- ON. THERE
A SOLUTION. AS WELL AS SEEING
THAT PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS WERE
PULLED IN TO HELP WITH MEDICARE
ALL AS WELL AS MCO WHICH- HAS
NOW BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE IS
MEETING ITS GOALS TO HELP TO
SUPPORT A HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT TOO IS IN
CRISIS IN THIS MOMENT. SO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR ALLOWING
ME TO ASK QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
DOCTOR READ MISTER FULL. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
WANNA START OFF WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION CERTAINLY. IN
TIMES OF CRISIS I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO BE OVER
COMMUNICATING A NOT ONLY WITH
THE PUBLIC BUT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE OUR OWN
PERSPECTIVE YEAR AND ONE ECHO-
THE COMMENTS FROM THE CHAIR AND
THE VICE CHAIR BUT JUST TO BE
FAIR WHAT WHAT GRADE WILL GIVE.
NOW FOR THE ADMINISTRATION IN
CONSULTATION WITH LET. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M IN THAT
POSITION AND TO ASSIGN GRADES-
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION I THINK
ALL I CAN SAY AND I KNOW THIS
IS TRUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
ALSO CERTAINLY TO STAFF THAT
WE'VE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
THERE'S- A PEOPLE ARE WORKING
DAY AND NIGHT AND EVERYBODY'S
DOING. THE BEST WE CAN AND I
THINK WE ALSO- AS MY COLLEAGUE-
YES THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR SAID
THAT- WE CERTAINLY HAVEN'T DONE
EVERYTHING. PERFECTLY AND WE
LEARN THE LESSONS- FROM WHAT
WE'VE DONE SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO TRY TO ACT OKAY AS
BEST AS WE CAN AND WE'RE
LICENSE FROM THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS AND MONTHS. HI STEVE WITH
AN AYE AYE NINETY ONE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK THAT
THAT. YOU IN AND YOUR- STAFF
HAVE BEEN PUTTING INTO THIS I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF TOUGH.
DECISIONS OF THAT THAT THE
MADE- IN TERMS OF THE- THE
FEDERAL MONEY THE TRIGGER CUTS.
OUT WHAT. WE WANT TO DELVE INTO
THE KIND OF MORE TO THE DETAILS
OF THE QUESTION FOR THE VICE
CHAIR BUT WHY. IS THAT THIS WHY
IS THE CHOICE OF THE TRIGGER
BECAUSE BINARY- IF. LESS MONEY
WAS RECEIVED BUT IT IS
SIGNIFICANT SOME WERE TO COME
IN. WHY IS THAT THE APPROPRIATE
APPROACH TO NOT. OF REEVALUATE
THE TRIGGER CUTS. TO PAY THAT
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH IS
RECEIVED. FROM FOR GOVERNMENT.
WHY IS IT WHY THE FOURTEEN
BILLION OR NOT OR AND OR
NOTHING. YES THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND I SHOULD.
EMPHASIZE THAT IF WE GET LESS
THAN FOURTEEN BILLION I'M IT'S
NOT THAT WE LOSE THE MONEY OR
THAT THE MONEY GOES OF WHY-
INTACT AND I KNOW ONE OF THE
BROADER THEMES OF THIS HEARING.
IS ADJUDICATING AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE PROPER
BALANCE. BETWEEN LEGISLATIVE
AND EXECUTIVE DISCRETION WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE DECISIONS SO.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS SPECIFIC
PROVISION ON IF IT'S LESS THAN
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS ON IT
I THEIR- RETURNS TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR APPROPRIATION.
UNLESS SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED
FOR COVERT NINETEEN RESPONSE
AND MY COLLEAGUE I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT WITH REGARD TO CONTROL
SECTION. ELEVEN NINETY FIVE THE
EMERGENCY EXIT. BUT IT DOES
COME LESS THAN. FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS. WE SIR. ALWAYS THAT
THE- OR THE DRUG OF FINANCE
READY. PICKS AND CHOOSES- AMONG
THE PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF WHAT
SHOULD BE FUNDED- CERTAINLY I
KNOW SOME SUGGESTED- PROVISIONS
WHERE THERE WOULD BE SOME KIND
OF PRO RATA- ACROSS THOSE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WHERE YOU
KNOW IF YOU GET HALF OF THE
MONEY. EACH CARD IS RESTORED BY
50% BUT- OUR INTERPRETATION IN
TERMS OF WHAT WOULD BE PASSED
IS THAT IF WE GET THAT WHOLE
AMOUNT AND WE ARE CERTAINLY
HOPING IT PUSHED. EVERY WITH
OUR FEDERAL GET A CALL NOT ALL
THOSE BASS CARD BE RESTORED.
AND THAT WE DON'T IN FORTUNATE
SITUATION WHERE WE DON'T GET
THAT WHOLE AMOUNT. THEN WILL BE
A CONVERSATION WITH THIS WAY.
OR THAT ANY THAT IS FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS TYPICALLY
FOR COMING NINETEEN RESPONSE
THAT WE WOULD MAKE SURE TO
SPECIFICALLY FOR CO. IN
RESPONSE. IN THE- V. L. ONE
POINT A BILLION THAT WAS
RELEASED INITIALLY REQUESTED I
THINK IT'S FOR THIS AMOUNT OF
FOR THIS MONTH YOU'RE YOU WERE
LOOKING TO SPEND BUT THEY LET
THE MINISTRATIONS ASKING FOR
ONE POINT EIGHT THREE ONE
BILLION FLOW OF FOR- NECESSARY-
SPENDING FOR TILL JUNE
THIRTIETH IS THAT CORRECT. END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR YESTERDAY.
IN A YOU DETAILED AND
COLLEAGUES- THAT IN THE LETTER
THAT WAS RECEIVED- IF YOU BREAK
DOWN- AND BROAD CATEGORIES BUT-
MAYBE CAN YOU JUST SHARE CAN IS
THERE MORE A MORE DETAILED
BREAKDOWN I MEAN IT'S SO LIKE
ONE POINT THREE BILLION IT'S A
PICTURE OF YOU KNOW IN A
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
ARE THOSE FOR EXISTING
CONTRACTS ARE THE IS THE
MINISTRATION LOOKING TO GET NEW
CONTRACTS AND- FORCE. AND OF
COURSE IT AND IN THE OP. UNDER
THE OTHER ITEMS YOU KNOW HOW
DOES A BREAKDOWN SPECIFICALLY
OR WOULD WE BE ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION. YES TO SOME OF OUR
FONG LET ME TURN IT OVER TO A
COUPLE OF MY COLLEAGUES AT TO
SEE WHAT THEY HAVE READY TO
SHARE RIGHT NOW AND WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE WE CAN ALSO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOUR OFFICE. I THREE
SEC OUR A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YES ATTACHED TO THE LETTER AND
IF YOU'RE- OUR OFFICE IN
RECEIVING WE CAN HELP MAKE SURE
YOU GUYS. THAT I'M LOOKING AT
OKAY THERE'S A VERY ATTACHMENT
THAT ATTEMPTS TO BREAK IT DOWN
TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION ON SOME OF THOSE
LARGE CATEGORIES A LARGE
CATEGORIES ARE. IN THE
NARRATIVE DESCRIBED WITH- THE
AMOUNT AND SO DID WITH THAT
HIGHER LEVEL CATEGORY BUT WE
DID ATTEMPT TO ALSO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONTEXT FOR
THEM ESPECIALLY THE HOSPITAL
MEDICAL SEARCH CATEGORY IN THE
PROCUREMENT CATEGORY
PARTICULAR. WITCHER SOME OF
THAT THE LARGER ARE THE LARGER
COMPONENTS TO THE REQUEST. OKAY
WELL I II AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I GUESS THE CHART IS BUT
CERTAINLY- GOOD I I'M JUST
TRYING TO THINK LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE IS AS MISS MCCARTY SET.
ME UP THERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET
PP IS WHAT ARE THE WHAT HOW
MANY CONTRACTS EXIST A
CONTRACTOR GAUCHE NEEDED. THAT
WE CERTAINLY THIS YEAR THANKS.
TRYING. A SHOP. OR LINE BY LINE
I. IS A FULL. YES FOR SOME OF
THESE FOR SOME OF THE THIS IS
THAT IS AND ARE WORK AND BASED
ON INITIAL WITH A STAFF WE ARE
ALREADY INTO WHAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION CAN PROVIDE AND
YOUR QUESTION OF THE NOTION OF
NEW VERSUS EXISTING CONTRACT IT
IS A BIT OF A MIX- AS PRIMARILY
EXISTING CONTRACTS BUT WE ARE
WORKING TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
EVEN. EVEN MORE GRANULAR LEVEL
OF DETAIL THAN WHAT THAT AND
WHAT IS PROVIDED IN THE- I
APPRECIATE THAT I MEAN I.
OTHERS A AND THIS CHAIRMAN THAT
I SAYING. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THE ONLY PREDICTOR OF FUTURE
BEHAVIOR IS PAST BEHAVIOR AND
RIGHT NOW. YOU CAN HEAR FROM US
IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE
PAST BEHAVIOR HAS HAS BEEN HAS
TAKEN PLACE AND SO- FROM FROM
MY VIEW AND I DON'T I WON'T
SPEAK FOR THE CHAIR BUT IF THAT
BEHAVIOR DOESN'T CHANGE. THE
LEGISLATURE WILL PHOTOGRAPHERS
IN TO ENSURE THAT WE- THAT WE
NEED I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RESPOND ONE OF
THE DOCTOR WERE NEXT YES WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR- FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION OF BEING HERE
TODAY. WE HAD INTERESTING
CONVERSATIONS ALSO YESTERDAY
THE PUBLIC SAFETY- COMMITTEE
AND CONCERN THAT WE PROBABLY
DIDN'T GET ALL THE ANSWERS THAT
WE WANTED TO GET AND SO MAYBE
SOME OF THE OF THE DIGITAL
STAFF THAT'S THERE TODAY CAN
PROBABLY ANSWER. ONE OF THE
THINGS OF COURSE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AS WE
LOOK AT THE BUDGET ITSELF THAT-
OF ALL THE ENTITIES- WITH
REGARDS TO WHO'S HAVING CUTS
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON. THE ONE
GROUP THAT SEEMS TO BE NOT
TAKING MANY CUTS THE CDC ARE.
IN TERMS OF ITS FAIR SHARE
CUTS. OF AND I SOON SOMEONE CAN
TELL US WHY. AND YET THERE ARE
THINGS CUT IN CDC ARE THAT ARE
PROBABLY MORE. ORIENTED TOWARD
WHAT THE MEMBERS WANTED TO YOU
KNOW ARE. ARE A- I SEX
TRAFFICKING OR SIX CRIME AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE IT'S IS SLATED TO
BE ELIMINATED. THE MONEY THAT
WE HAVE FOR- TRAINING AND POST
TRAINING IS BEING SHIFTED
AROUND AWAY FROM. WHAT WE
THOUGHT WOULD BE CONTINUING
ABOUT USE OF FORCE AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE- BIAS TRAINING AND
SO FORTH AND SO ON SO THERE'S
SOME. DECISIONS BEING MADE THAT
MAY NOT NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
MADE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
REALLY RELATED. TO THIS CRISIS
AND YET STILL KIND OF REMAIN
THE SITE. IS SOFT APPROACH AND
A DECISION FOLKS MAKING. AND
ARE COUNTED WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN IN THE
PAST THE RIGHT. INTO A PRO SO
WITH. OF I'M KINDA CUTE ABOUT
HOW STILL ARRIVE AT THE- AMOUNT
FIRST YEAH. AND YES SOME OF THE
PRO. WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT
TRAINING AND STICKS AMONG
PEOPLE IN. THIS BILL KIND OF.
THANK I GET THE NUMBER. RIGHT
PLACE IN TERMS OF THE IN SO I
MANY OF MARK WHO WHY DO SEES R.
SKATE ANYTIME OF WHAT WE IT
COULD TO BE REASONABLE. THE
OTHER THING I IS THAT YOU CAN
ANSWER FOR ME TO IS THAT WE ASK
THE QUESTION YESTERDAY ABOUT-
AND IDEA TO ABOUT THE- CLOSING
THE PRISONS THAT WE HAVE SLATED
TO CLOSE TWO PRISONS IN THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS AND THAT
SOUNDS GREAT UP IT WHAT WHAT
KIND OF WONDER ONE IS HOW CAN
WE PREDICT OF THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WOULD BE. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT CLOSE WE DON'T KNOW I
WOULD HAVE TO DO. WITH WITH
REGARD TO THE- IN TERMS OF
WHERE THESE THIS. PRISON A WHAT
SO HOW DO KNOW THAT. HOW MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO SAVE IF WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW THE PRISON THAT WERE
CLOSING THAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO
CLOSE- WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
THAT. THERE ARE STILL SOME-
CAPITAL OUTLAY THAT PEOPLE ARE
PROPOSING AND YET WE DON'T KNOW
WHICH PRISONS TO. TO CLOSE
BECAUSE WE'VE CONCERNS OF WE
DON'T. RIP ABATE PRISONS AND
THEN TEAR THEM DOWN SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY GET THIS SLATED TO
BE JUST UP TO BE. CLOSED IN YET
WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA AT ALL.
IT SEEMS IF GIVING FOR YOU TO
DETERMINE. WHICH ONES OF THE
PRISONS TO BE CLOSE TO SEE ACR.
AND WE HAVE ASKED CDC ARE FOR
THE- YEARS TO COME UP WITH A
PLAN. OF THE CLOSING PRISONS
AND HAVE NOT WRITTEN PROP. LINE
THAT IT MAKES. TO THE LOS WHAT.
IS OUT OF. WITH THIS AND IS TO
BE USED. SO WE SOME REAL
CONCERN ABOUT. HOW THIS BUT
FITS TOGETHER AND WITH THE NOT
THE- IS ACTUALLY. BECAUSEWE
DON'T SEE TO GET THE KIND OF
INFORMATION KIND OF PLANNING A
STRUCTURE- THAT SHOULD EXIST IF
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THESE MAJOR
MOVES. THE SAME IS TRUE WITH
THE- JUVENILE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
PROPOSING TO BE MOVED WE SCRIPT
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME LAST
YEAR TALKING ABOUT IT TO END UP
WITH NOTHING NOBODY MOVE
ANYWHERE. NO MONEY WAS IT ALL I
MEAN A LOT OF CONVERSATION A
POLICY PEOPLE SPEND MONEY GOING
ON TRIPS. AND FOR HAVING
CONVERSATIONS BUT IN THE END WE
END UP WITH DJJ STILL IN THIS
PLACE. DESPITE THE EFFORTS TO
SAYS IS GOING TO GO MOVED INTO
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT. SO
THERE'S ALL THESE THINGS ARE
HERE IN THE BUDGET THAT IT JUST
KIND OF SLOW. DOWN AND IT
DOESN'T PEERS IF THERE'S PATH.
TO CHRISTMAS SO MAYBE. SOME TO
TELL US AND THEN ON TOP OF ALL
OF THAT YOU PLAN TO. AFTER WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME FIGHTING TO
GET OUR INSPECTOR GENERAL. IN A
POSITION TO BASICALLY BE IN
CHARGE OF ALL OF THIS AND MAKE
SURE THERE'S A SEPARATE POINT
OF VIEW WITH. ALL THE
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE COMING IN
AND OUT CONCERNING PRISONS. OF
WE END UP AT THE SAME TIME US.
TRY LOCAL. A MUSLIM. OPERATION
THIS IS. IT ALL THESE PEOPLE
LIMóN EIGHT PURPOSE OF THAT
WOULD TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
GOING HAPPEN. WE HAVE A
COMPLAIN GOING LIKE CRAZY
COMING IN CONCERNING THE FOR-
HERE TALKING ABOUT CLOSING
PRISON WHAT KIND OF FIGURE OUT
HOW WHICH ONES LEAVE
INNOVATIONS WHICH ONES DON'T.
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR THE WARNS
OF KNOCK ON TELESCOPES NOBODY
ONCE IT'S CLOSE THE PRISON SAID
THEM YEAH. SO THERE IS HOPE HER
EXPECTED GENERAL. SUPPOSE WE
TRIED ALL THE STUFF NOW WE'RE
HAVING YOU GUYS CUT HIS
PROGRAM. AND YET AT THE END. I
LIVE IN I HAVE I STILL HAVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY GOING
INTO. INTO THIS WHILE REDUCING
POPULATIONS AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON SO. MAYBE YOU CAN GIVE ME
SOME INSIGHT IT AS MY STAFF OF
THE MEMBERS. CAN ASK. ESTá HOW
RIGHT AT. LEAST THAT'S HOW DO
WE ARRIVE AT. THE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE HERE THAT HAVE BEEN
ON. THE BOOKS FOR. TO YEARS. AT
NO STAY. TAKEN EVEN. MEANT ANY
OF THESE PROPOSED AND I'VE IN A
IN ORDER NOT FASHION. AND SO
IT'S THESE VERY DISTANT.
VILLAGES IT STOP. AT THIS UP.
WE AND THESE. IS FOR. DON'T
HAVE ANY ANSWER THE WOULD MAKE
TO MAKE HIS MOVE IN A STANDARD.
AND MY FEET IS THAT WHEN MONEY
COMES IN BECAUSE WE. DON'T HAVE
I AM. NOT WOULD YOU. IT FOR THE-
WE WILL DOUBLE WHAT THEY LARGE
BUDGET OUT THAN WHAT IS TO BE
WE BE IN A FOR WHERE WE TO PAY
FOR ALL THIS STUFF THAT WE
CLING WILL TO ELIMINATE THAT WE
DID. SO WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT
THAT. YEAH WELL DOCTOR A WEBER
I WILL SAY I DON'T MY PUBLIC
SAY COLLEGE WITH ME BY YOU KNOW
DAY. IT IS CERTAINLY HAPPEN A
NUMBER OF THE TO SAY ABOUT THIS
ISSUES I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
ANSWER ALL THOSE THOSE ARE ALL
REALLY GOOD QUESTIONS AND- THEY
JUST- YOU KNOW THEY TELL ME
THEY'RE WATCHING AS WELL SO
THEY WILL. FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
THAT'S THE CAT- BUT HUNTING
YESTERDAY EITHER SO OKAY. OKAY
YEAH SO I WILL MAKE SURE FIRST
OF ALL THAT- OUR DEAL OF
COLLEAGUES WHO WORK ON PUBLIC
SAFETY GET BACK TO ON THESE
ISSUES- I WILL JUST MAKE. THREE
POINTS. OUT THAT I KNOW YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE BROADER
STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET AND-
CDC ARE TO THE POINTS YOU
MENTIONED. THE FIRST POINT IS
THAT. WHEN IT COMES. YOU AT CDC
ALL. PARTICULAR THERE SURE ARE
SOME COURT ORDERED MANDATES.
THAT WE HAVE TO COMPLY WITH AS
A STATE YOU KNOW UNDER- UNDER
THE ORDER OF A JUDGE. SO FOR
THIS REASON. SOME OF THE
SPENDING- AND- MADE THE POINT-
DOESN'T GET REDUCED- THE WAY
SPENDING IN OTHER CATEGORIES-
MIGHT. HAVE TO BE REDUCED TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET. SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THESE COURT ORDERED
MANDATES AND CERTAINLY. THE
STATE. GOVERNOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. AGREES WITH YOU
IT AT. WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN OVER TIME TO. IMPROVE
REHAB REHABILITATION- AND
CONTINUE. DOWN TREND. STATE AND
POPULATION BUT- I SUPPORT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND IT SAVES.
BUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING- THAT
CAN BE DONE. IN JUST ONE YEAR-
BUT THE SECOND POINT. WHICH YOU
ALLUDED TO IS. WHEN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED HIS BUDGET IN
JANUARY. PROPOSED CLOSING. UP
ONE PRESENT. NOW WITH THE MAY
REVISION OVER. FIVE YEARS NOW
THE MAYOR- HE IS ABOUT
PROPOSING A CURRENT POPULATION
TRENDS HOLD. THE CLOSER. TO
PRESIDENTS AND NOW. IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY RIGHT NOW-
EXACTLY WHAT THE SAVINGS WILL
BE BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW. WHEN
THE FACILITIES EXACTLY WILL BE
CLOSED. THE METS. OR WHAT SIZE
FACILITY WILL BE CLOSED. THAT'S
BASED ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS. I REMEMBER TALKING TO
CHARGE HIM. WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU. WHAT IS THE ISSUE. IS
THAT. I'M GOING STAVING. ONCE
DISCLOSURE DOES COME TO. PASS
THAT. OPEN AT. TEN THOSE ARE
THE SAVINGS THAT WE- HE- AND
BUDGET FOR THAT CATEGORY. ON
THE DOES ARE THE TWO MAIN
POINTS AND I THINK LAST POINT
IS. YOU MENTION DJJ. AT THAT
NOW THE- GOAL IS TO. REALIZE
THAT THE COUNTY. AND I KNOW.
THAT. WILL BE ABLE TO. BUY MORE
DETAIL ON. BEFORE WE REALIZE
WHAT THE NOT THIS IS ACTUALLY A
BALANCED BUDGET OR NOT AND EVEN
IF WE MAKE REVISIONS INTO JULY
OR- AUGUST. WE NEED TO KNOW IF
THESE A REALITY THAT THIS STUFF
WILL ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE. AND
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
BASICALLY SEE THAT. THE RESULTS
THAT WE THINK WE SHOULD SEE IN
TERMS OF THAT. THE OTHER PIECE
THAT IT DIDN'T I MEAN SINCE.
MUCH OF THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
COVERT RELATED- TERMS OF. WHAT
WE'RE DOING. HOW DOES YOU KNOW
WE ARE FACED RIGHT NOT AYE
PRISONS WITH AN INCREASE. IN
THE VIRUS. AND OF THE DRAMATIC%
INCREASE IN SOME OF THE
PRISONS- AND YET I DON'T SEE A
WHOLE LOT OF PLAN HERE AS TO
HOW WE'RE GOING TO RESPOND TO
IT. AND THE DATA WE GOT THE
OTHER DAY MY STAFF GOT ME DATA
CONCERNING. OF THE INFECTIONS
NOT ONLY A YOU KNOW YOU GET
LIKE. TWO STAFF PEOPLE GET
INFECTION AND THEN WE LOOK UP
THE NEXT WEEK OR SO WE GOT A
HUNDRED. PRISONERS WITH THE
SAME WITH THE INFECTION SO I
MEAN IT AND- AND SO IT'S REALLY.
OF BECAUSE AND I KNOW THIS TEST.
BUT I DON'T SEE EVEN A PLAN TO
TALK ABOUT. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO WITH. IN THE TACKLE. IN
TERMS OF. FOLKS ARE GETTING THE
INFECTION WE CAN'T JUST LET IT
HAPPEN I MEAN WHICH IS A
ALMOST. THE THOUGHT IT SENSIBLE
TO SAY. THAT THESE ARE THAT.
WAS THE THOUGHT THAT MAYBE
THESE ARE EXPENDABLE PEOPLE
WHICH I DON'T THINK THERE'S
SUCH. A GROUP ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH THAT ARE EXPENDABLE
BUT- CLEARLY- UP I WOULD ASSUME
THAT THERE'S THAT MUCH OF A
SOME OF THE CONVERSATION. WOULD
BE A RAP ON WOULD BE DOING WITH
THE PRISON POPULATION. AND I
KNOW MY COMMITTEE WE'VE ASKED
AND WE HAVEN'T REALLY GOTTEN A
VERY GOOD PLAN. AS TO WHAT'S
GOING TO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OUR PRISONS WITH REGARDS TO THE
INFECTION AND THAT LOOKS LIKE
THOSE PLACES ARE GOING TO BE
THE HOT SPOTS. YES I WANTED
OPPOSITION FIRST. TO TRY YOUR
POINT WANT TO CLARIFY MAKE VERY
CLEAR THAT THERE IS NO OF
EXPENDABLE POPULATION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S TOP OF MIND
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION- AND YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE STEPS THAT WE
DID TAKE WAS TAKING STEPS TO
PAUSE AND TAKES OF THAT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN. IN THE
IMMEDIATE TERM WHAT THIS
EMERGENCY OUT REGULATE THE
POPULATION SO THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO MAKE PROGRESS GIVEN THIS
AGENCY I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON SOME OF THE DETAILS
IN TERMS OF THE PLAN FORWARD
THAT YOU MENTIONED OF MY
COLLEAGUE MARCO IS HERE- I DO
WANT TO CHECK. IF HE MAY BE
ABLE TO SAVE ITS OFFICE MIGHT
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL. DR
WEBBER MY NAME IS MARK IMAGINE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH OUR CDC
COLLEAGUES AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AS WELL AS
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS WOULD THAT HAVE
PRESENCE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
AT THE STATE LEVEL. ARE DOING
TWO THINGS ONE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AROUND INFECTIOUS DISEASE
CONTROL. AND MEASURES THAT EACH
OF THE PRESENCE CAN TAKE IN
ORDER TO MITIGATE THE SPREAD
OF. SLOW THIS OF THE VIRUS THEN
THE- THINGS. AND WE'RE ACT.
WORKING WITH REGARDS WITH CDC
ARE I HAVE WITH REGARDS TO
TESTING. AND THE ABOUT THE HAVE
CDC ARE TO BE ABLE TO TEST IN
EACH ONE OF THOSE PRESENT SO.
WE ARE BOTH PRIVATE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO CDC
ARNIE OF THE INDIVIDUAL
PRESENCE FROM THE STATE LEVEL.
BUT WE'RE ALSO WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE LOCAL PUBLIC
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE PRESENCE
IN THE- STATION. SOUNDS GOOD
WE- CAN HOLD TO THAT I WOULD
NEED THE ACTION THAT WAS TAKEN
TO. PLEASE STOP. NOW FOLKS
BEING ADMITTED IN HAVING THEM.
IN THE- THAT DOING THAT TIME
FRAME THAT THEY WOULD BE PUT IN
PLACE A VERY. ACTIVE AND
CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD PROCESS OF
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE PRISONS IN
TERMS OF. LETTING AN ADDITIONAL
FOLKS TESTING FOLKS WHO LIED SO
FORTH AND SO ON AND WE BASS FOR
THAT AND HAVE YET TO RECEIVE. A
CLEAR SET OF. GUIDELINES OF
STANDARDS THAT ARE BEING USED
TO- FOR THE EVEN IF WE'RE
LETTING FOLKS OUT. A COUPLE OF
MONTHS. YOU HAVE THE ALL THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PROTESTED BEFORE
THEY SENT TO THE COMMUNITY. OF
THOSE WHO BEING BLOODY AND HAVE
THEY BEEN TESTED YOU KNOW AND
IF THEY ARE WHAT DO THEY GOAL
AND WEARS A BIT AND YOU KNOW
HOW WE CAN DOING THIS. AND IT
AND THEN IN ADDITION THAT ARE
WE TESTING OUR STAFF WILL
PROBABLY BRING IN ANY AND- AND
SO. THAT THE THAT'S- THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS THAT
WE THOUGHT OF DOING THAT
HIATUS. I WOULDN'T AND MEETING
WILL THAT. BE AND HE'S BUDGET
TALK ABOUT THAT PLAN. AND DOES
NOT THAT WE HAVE NOT REACHED
THE POINT. WE CAPS PEOPLE. WERE
ALL WORKING TO THEIR I DON'T
THAT. OF BECAUSE SEE THE IN.
SEEN THE ACT JACK. OR SOMETHING.
IS THIS. WE DO. WHEN IT. IN
THESE. DAYS OF ASPECT THAT WE
HAVE TO FACTOR IN. IN TERMS OF
HAND. THE VIRUS. I HOPE AT SOME
POINT WE SEE ACTUAL. BUT THAT
WOULD BE THE- AS WE TRYING TO
RE OPEN THE REST OF THE
SOCIETY. THAT WE DON'T END UP
WITH THESE HORRIBLE HOT SPOT
WELL THAT WOULD LETTING PEOPLE
OUT WHO ARE INFECTED. OF
WITHOUT ANY- INFORMATION AND
THEY'RE GOING BACK INTO THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND WE INFECTING FOLKS. THANK
YOU. LOOK AT. WHAT I'M JUST
GOING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
JUST BROKE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. COUPLE OF MY COLLEAGUES
BROUGHT UP THE MASK THE ISSUE.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE STARTED
GETTINGAN INFLUXOF PEOPLE
SAYING THEY HAD P. P. YOU KNOW
I COMMENDED YOU FOR CREATING
THAT WEBSITE THAT PEOPLE COULD
GO THROUGH AND BE VETTED- TO
FIND. ACTORS AND WRITERS BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE. THE
RESTORATION THEIR OWN PROTOCOL
AND I HAD PEOPLE CONTACTING MY
OFFICE AND I JUST I SENT IN TO
THAT WEBSITE WHICH IS VERY
HELPFUL BUT SEEMS LIKE YOU GUYS
ONE OFF ON YOUR OWN AND I WANT
TO GO BACK BECAUSE I MENTIONED
THIS IN THE APRIL TWENTIETH
HEARING. IS THAT PART OF THE B.
Y. DE. MA'AM WAS THAT THERE A
QUIT THEY WERE THE FIRST ONES
THERE QUICK MEMBERS ALREADY
CERTIFIED BY THE FDA- SO IS
THAT MEMO IN CORRECTED THEY
OVERSELL. WHAT THEY'RE OFFERING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. CURRY
WITH CAL- YES AGAIN SO THERE'S
TWO PARTS TO CERTIFICATION
THERE'S THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION FDA AND THEN I
OFF WHICH IS A DIFFERENT-
CERTIFICATION THIS THIS TO THE
END NINETY FIVE. PRODUCT THE
RESPIRATOR AND THAT IS UNDER
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SOUTH- SAID THE FDA- PART OF IT
WAS AND WAS IN PLACE ALREADY-
WITH THEIR FACTOR WITH THEIR
PRODUCT THE PRODUCTION OF NYE
OFSHE- CERTIFIED AND NINETY
FIVE MASK WAS THE PIECE THAT
WAS NOT YET IN PLACE WITH THE
CONTACT THEIR WORKING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW. FOLLOW UP AND WAITED
DETAIL ANONYMOUS TECHNICAL
PART- IF I AM NOT ABLE TO
ANSWER THE SPECIFICS BUT-
THAT'S THE- YOU KNOW KIND OF
THE HIGH LEVEL. MAYBE I'M NOT A
MEDICAL PERSON MAYBE YOU CAN
JUST EXPLAIN TO MAY AND THE
PUBLIC WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN IT AND NINETY FIVE AND
A QUE AND NINETY FIVE. AND I AM
I'M NOT A MEDICAL PERSON EITHER
BUT TO THE CANE AND NINETY FIVE
IS A PRODUCT THAT NORMALLY IS
NOT USED IN THE YOU ASKED FOR-
RESPIRATORS WORD AND NINETY
FIVE IT IS THE CAN YOU LAST
NIGHT HOURS THE FIRE. PRODUCT
THERE WAS SOME EMERGENCY RELIEF
FOR I DON'T I BELIEVE IN THE US
EIGHT BY THE- FEDERAL
REGULATORS YOU USE THAT K. F.
NINETY FIVE. THE A STRANGE
SITUATION. GENERALLY THAT'S MY
ADDRESS IN AGAIN YOU KNOW WANT
TO HEAR ABOUT ALL THE TECHNICAL
WITH OUR OUR EXPERTS IN THIS
AREA BUT THAT THE THAT'S AGAIN
A HIGH LEVEL SO HOW MANY MASS
DEALS WERE THERE WE'VE READ
ABOUT THE WHITE DE THERE WAS A-
DAIMLER COMPANY WAS A BLUE
POINT OR SOMETHING THAT WAS THE
ONE THAT WAS IN BUSINESS FOR
THREE DAYS AND THE BANK
NOTIFIED THE TREASURER. THE
DOORS MISSION BUT HOW MANY HOW
MANY DEALS ARE THEY- I'LL HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
SPECIFICS WE HAVE POSTED ALL
THE CONTRACTS ON OUR WEBSITE-
THERE'S MOUSE BUT THERE'S A
OTHER COMMODITIES IT BEEN
PURCHASED. FOR THAT PANDEMIC
BUT- YOU KNOW THAT WE WERE
ORDERING IN QUANTITIES THAT WE
COULD RECEIVE TO SOME OF THE-
VENDORS WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SMALL QUANTITIES OF CERTAIN
THINGS. I'M NOT ONLY OTHER MASS
AND NINETY FIVE SURGICAL BUT
THERE'S ALSO FACE SHIELDS
GOWNS- SANITIZERS YOU KNOW VERY
VERY AS COMMODITIES THAT WERE
NEEDED- IN MAY AND THE OB AT
SCALE. THE AND THAT MAKES.
THERE'S A VARIETY OF THOSE SAYS
THEY ARE DIFFERENT SIZES THE
REASON THERE ARE MULTIPLE IS
BECAUSE WE WERE. TRYING TO
REACH BOWLS OF QUANTITY AND
WE'RE GETTING- DOES FEEL THAT
WE COULD WHEN WE COULD SO HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH THAT. THANKS
I THINK TO THE WHOLE COMMITTEE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN SEEING.
THE EXTENT OF THE DEALS. ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE PAID. WHAT WE'VE
GOTTEN IN PP AND WHERE YOU'VE
SENT THAT WHETHER IT'S
HOSPITALS OR FRONTLINE WORKERS
OR FIREFIGHTERS OR DAYCARE
COULD BE JUST THE PROCESS WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL TO ME AND THE
AND THE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE-
LET ME ASK YOU A- SO. IN THE
TWENTIETH HEARING IT WAS TOLD
TO US THAT YOU GUYS WERE
FOLLOWING THE HOPKINS MODEL-
FOR TRENDS THROUGH ALL THIS
HAVE YOU GONE BACK AND TRIED
TO- RE CALIBRATE ANY OF THESE
TRENDS BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME
YOU KNOW THE MATT THING WAS A
BIG DEAL IT FOR SENATE DIED
DOWN NOW THE MASS THINGS A BIG
DEAL AGAIN. AND IT WILL THEN.
WE NEED ALL THESE VENTILATORS
AND WE DIDN'T NEED THE
VENTILATORS AND THE GOVERNOR
LOANS AND OTHER STATES. AND
THEN WE ARE GEARING UP FOR A
FIFTY THOUSAND HOSPITAL BEDS
THAT DIDN'T MATERIALIZE. ARE
YOU GUYS WHAT WHAT IS YOUR
STRATEGY GOING FORWARD AND
WHO'S BUYING ON- FOR THESE
NUMBERS. THE STUFF THAT WE- FOR
THE PAST HASN'T REALLY ME
BLOCKS. SO I'M GONNA OVER TO
MARK. COLLEAGUE FROM HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WHO CAN PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION ON MODELING
AND WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
REMEMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION SO- LET ME BREAK
UP THE QUESTION INTO A FEW
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS FIRST AND
FOREMOST- THE REASON WHY WE PUT
THE STATE HOME ORDER CAME
PLACES THE REASON WHY. WE DON'T
SEE THE TRENDS THAT WE SEE IN
OTHER STATES AND OTHER
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD WITH
REGARDS TO BOTH THE CASE
POSITIVE ADD TO AND DOES IS
BECAUSE WE TAKE ACTION-
QUICKLY. AND THE STATE OR
MORTAR AND THE ACTIONS OF THE
GOVERNOR DID TWO THINGS THEY
ALLOWED US TO BUY TIME IN ORDER
TO DECOMPRESS OUR HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM SO THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO RESPOND. MORE WE
HAD A LOT. TO PREPARE AND- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THIS EXPERIENCE IS
THAT PEOPLE REALLY DID HEED THE
ADVICE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS BOTH AT THE STATE
LEVEL. AND UP A WHOLE LOT OF
ALL WITH REGARD TO STAYING AT
HOME. OUT AT REALLY. WITH
REGARD TO AT AMP. SURGE WE ARE
VERY FOR. THAT WE DIDN'T AFTER
ACTIVATE ANY TO OF ANSWER CAL.
THAT NOT MEAN THAT WE MIGHT NOT
HAVE A SEARCH AS WE BEGIN
MODIFICATIONS WITH REGARDS TO
THE STAY AT HOME ORDER WOULD
TERE ARE A NUMBER OF FACTORS
DRIVING OUR ABILITY TO TERM AND
KIND OF WHAT THIS. WHAT THINGS
OF HOW THINGS WILL LOOK LIKE
WITH REGARDS TO THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS AND ARE MARKED. FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE DO NOT KNOW AT
THE SEASONALITY OF THIS VIRUS
WE MIGHT ASSUME THAT
TEMPERATURES MIGHT THAT DUE DUE
TO THE TEMPERATURE CHANGE THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE VIRUS. WE
BELIEVE. THERE IS SOME RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT AT THE VIRUS DOES
BEHAVE BASED ON TEMPERATURES
BECAUSE OF ONE COMPONENT OF
THE- CORONAVIRUS WHICH IS A AT
THE COMMON COLD. BEHAVE THAT
WAY NOW- WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THE NOVEL CORONAVIRUS WILL
BEHAVE THAT WAY. OTHER
COMPONENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT AS WE BEGIN TO LOOK
AT- THE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
STATE HOME ORDERED A POTENTIAL
SEARCH EITHER IN THE FALL OR IN
THE COMING WEEKS. IS HOW
INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIOR MIGHT
CHANGE. AS WE MAKE THESE
MODIFICATIONS HOW WOULD YOU ONE
NIGHT AND OUR OTHER
CALIFORNIANS REACT AND HOW THEY
ACT IN THE PUBLIC. EYE WHEN WE
MAKE THESE MODIFICATIONS MORE
IMPORTANTLY. PART PART AND
OTHER MUSICIANS IN THE
COMMUNITY OF WHAT PRECAUTIONS
THEY TAKE. A NAP COUPLE. MAKE
THE- ASIAN WE MIGHT HAVE SAID
THOSE ARE ALL THE DIFFERENT
FACTORS THAT GO INTO. THANK
YOU. WE. THANK YOU ON TOP WE
ALSO USE THE NUMBER OTHER
MODELS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE FORTY I THINK NOW IS THAT
WE SOME ACT DATE AROUND THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE VIRUS IN
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE WE'RE USING THAT ACTUAL
DATA TO REALLY DRIVE OUR
DECISION MAKING. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME LOOKING AT NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL PROJECTIONS
WITH REGARDS TO THE BEHAVIOR OF
THE FIRE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MARK GOING TO PLEASE DON'T TAKE
MY QUESTION IS CRITICAL WERE
ALL INTO UNCHARTED TERRITORIES
AND HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. YOU KNOW AS WE'RE SITTING
HERE NOW IT I MEAN IT'S GOING
TO BE SOME LEAN BUDGET YEARS
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
QUESTIONS OF THE MASS COME UP.
I MEAN WE'RE GONNA BE TIGHT FOR
DOLLARS FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE. WE'RE
SPENDING THOSE WISELY ON THINGS
WE ACTUALLY NEED SO THANKS FOR
THAT MIGHT MY FINAL QUESTION IS
FOR FINANCE. AND GOING BACK TO
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIRS
COMMENTS ABOUT. THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT I JUST WANNA. WHY DO
YOU WHY DO YOU FEEL THE NEED
THAT YOU WANT TO BE THE-
DECISION MAKER OF. OF
ALLOCATING THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT MAY COME IN. ON THAT
QUESTION WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS I THINK- WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO A SPECIFIC-
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING. WHEN IT COMES TO-
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY AND YOU
KNOW WE ARE I'VE BEEN AN
EMERGENCY- SINCE THE GOVERNOR
AND MADE HIS DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY AND I THINK WHAT THIS
VIRUS- MY COLLEAGUE MARCO WAS
DISCUSSING THE DIFFERENT MODELS
AND- HOW WE THINK ABOUT IT BUT
ONE THING THAT WE DO KNOW. IS
THAT THIS CAN CHANGE VERY
QUICKLY AND WE'VE CERTAINLY
SEEN THAT DIVERSITY OF OUT
TIMES EVEN WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES FROM STATE TO STATE AND
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MOVING VRY
CAREFULLY AND DISCIPLINED WAY.
COMES TO RE OPENING THE ECONOMY
BUT WE'RE ALL OF US DID BY WHAT
OTHER STATES IN THE US DO. AND
WE'RE ALSO AFFECTED BY UNKNOWNS
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS VIRUS SO
THE REASON THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING THE FLEXIBILITY. IS
SO THAT THE STATE CAN. IF YOU
HAVE TO AND THAT SUMMER AND
FALL. IN PER YEAR AWAY IF THE
WATCHED. IS OUT OF SESSION OR
OTHERWISE CANNOT ACT IN A VERY
QUICK MANNER BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF ENGAGEMENT-
AND CLEAR NOTIFICATION AND
WERE. CONTINUING TO IMPROVE OUR
PROCESSES WHEN IT COMES TO THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO PUT
OUT THAT WHETHER WE KNOW CAME
LATE LAST NIGHT. BUT DECLARE
FIRE EXPENDITURES SO THAT
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THAT.
EVEN BEFORE THIS HEARING TODAY
AS WELL AS HEADING INTO NEXT
WEEK SO I KNOW WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO GET THE BALANCE RIGHT. BUT I
THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- ALSO DO FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT. THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME PROVISION IF THERE
IS A RESURGENCE OR NEED TO STEP
UP HOSPITALS ARE AGAIN. THAT WE
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO DO THAT
VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE THAT IS A
CORE FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT IN
AN EMERGENCY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THANK FOR THE TIMES
CHAIR. THANK YOU THE OTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE I GET TO MY
QUESTIONS AND JUST LOOK AT THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY TO STORE A
COUPLE COUPLE FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS- JUST GOING BACK TO
THIS MAY TWENTY FIRST LETTER.
CAN YOU JUST WALK US THROUGH
WHY THE- THEY NEED TO DO THIS-
THE TRIO- ALLOCATION AT THIS
POINT WHEN WE ARE. SORT OF ALL
IN ALL IN SESSION WE'RE ALL
HERE THERE WAS NO- NOTIFICATION
THERE WAS NO HEADS UP THERE WAS
NO DISCUSSION. SO JUST WALK US
THROUGH THE THAT THAT THINKING.
SURE LET ME- I'LL JUST MAKE THE
ONE POINT THAT THIS IS FOR
CURRENT YEAR EXPENDITURES BUT I
THINK YOU'RE ASKING THE BROADER
QUESTION ABOUT THE THINKING
BEHIND IT AND LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO RECYCLE
FOR. YES THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING WE EVER REALLY. TRIED TO.
AND THIS LETTER NOT ONLY
DESCRIBE THE CURRENT YEAR
DOLLARS FOR THE JURY
ALLOCATION. BUT ALSO LAY OUT
THE PLAN AS IT IS REFLECTED IN
THE REVISION AND ARMING
REVISION FIGURES. SAID THE
DRILL ALLOCATION FOR THE SKI
SAYS ON THE ONE TWENTY THREE
BILLION. THREE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. REALLY REFLECTS THINGS
AGAIN THAT ARE. KIND OF UNDER
WAY IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
EXPECTED. AND FOR THE REMAINING
WEEKS OF THE CURRENT YEAR. AB
THERE ARE AS AS WAS NOTED
EARLIER VARIOUS CATEGORIES BUT
WE REALLY DID TRY TO LAY OUT.
NOT ONLY THE CURRENT YOUR PART
BUT ALSO TO GIVE FURTHER DETAIL
ON THE MAY REVISION. OF
ASSUMPTIONS AND SO THAT WAS THE
GOAL OF THIS LETTER WAS TO
PROVIDE EVEN MORE DETAIL THAT
WAS. THAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE
RIVER BUT IS CONSISTENT WITH
OUR MAIN REVISION ESTIMATES. NO
NO I UNDERSTAND THAT DISEASE
CAN YOU JUST ME THROUGH WHAT
WHY THERE WAS NO. LEGISLATIVE
BRIEFING THERE WAS NO- IT'LL
IT'S IT WAS THAT WE WERE
DIFFICULT TO REACH WERE WE
UNAVAILABLE. PERHAPS YOU WERE
BUSY. YES MISTER KING I THINK-
WE WERE- FINALIZING AT TWO
BECAUSE THE SITUATION IS
CHANGING ON A DAILY BASIS- THIS
WAS PART OF UPDATING OUR
ESTIMATES FOR THE NAY REVISION
AND CLARIFYING THEM AND PUTTING
THEM INTO A FORMAT THAT WE
COULD SHARE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO WE- AND I
CAN CONFIRM THIS WE DID NOT
FINALIZE WHAT WE SHARED- LAST
NIGHT AND TOLD VERY SHORTLY-
BEFORE WE DID SHARE IT- WE HAD
A CALL. WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF
OUT BEFORE WE ACTUALLY- SHARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN WALK
THEM THROUGH- SOME OF THE KEY
PROVISIONS SO WE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A VERY FLUID SITUATION
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO.
IMPROVE AT AND FOR THE LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION BUT WE DID SHARE
THAT AS SOON AS IT WAS READY. I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY A POINT
AND- MY COLLEAGUES TO CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG- BLOODLUST
CHECKED IT CONSTITUTION
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO SUBSTITUTE
IT JUST TORE. SO ARE. BIG
DIFFERENCE TELLING ME SOMETHING
PERSIST HAULING MY STAFF
SOMETHING. SO THERE WAS NO
CALIFORNIA AND THAT ELECTED ANY
ONE OF MY STAFF MEMBERS LAST I
CHECKED. SO AGAIN YOU HAVE
CURRENT YOUR REVISIONS AND
RATHER THAN CALL US HOW THE
MEETING DISCUSS IT WITH US YOU
SENT A FORMAL LETTER. IS THIS
THE CAN IS THIS THIS IS THE
PATTERN THAT YOU CONTINUE TO.
ANTICIPATE ACTING DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG THIS PANDEMICS GONNA GO
FOR COULD BE. TWO THREE YEARS.
WE COULD BE LIVING AGAIN IN A
POST COVERT NINETEEN PERIOD
FOREVER. AS ALL THE MEDICAL
DOCTORS HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THERE'S THIS DISEASE IS NOT
GOING AWAY. SO IS THIS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO
CONTINUE OPERATE. DURING THIS
COVER NINETY WHICH COULD BE FOR
THE REST OF THE PERIOD OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S EXISTENCE. I
THINK WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO SHARE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS WE CAN AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN AND- AND I
KNOW WE WERE WORKING ON
FINALIZING THIS INFORMATION ON
WHICH HAS BEEN UPDATED SINCE WE
WERE ALL TOGETHER LAST MONTH
WHEN WE INITIALLY PROJECTED A
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE- BUT I HEAR YOUR
FEEDBACK MISTER TECH AND I'LL
MAKE SURE TO SHARE IT WITH. A
MENTAL IMAGES CLEAR BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THIS DISCUSSION WITH MY
STAFFAS WELL JUST BECAUSE YOU
HIT SEND. IN AN EMAIL. THE
ACCOUNT HAS INFORMING ME. SO
YOUR IDEA OF COMMUNICATION IS
SENDING ME A FORM LETTER VIA
EMAIL. THAT'S NOT COMMUNICATION
I HOPE THAT'S NOT HOW PEOPLE
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS IT'S DEFINITELY NOT HOW
WE ONLY COMMUNICATE WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS OTHERWISE WE'D ALL
BE FIRED. SO SENDING A LETTER
DOES NOT CONSTITUTE
COMMUNICATION. SO AGAIN. THIS
PANDEMIC JUST LIKE I OUTLINED
JUST LIKE WE HAVE HEART DISEASE
JUST LIKE WE HAVE CANCER WILL
BE PROBABLY BE HERE FOR THE
NEXT. SIX PLUS YEARS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S EXISTENCE
SHOULD THIS. TO THE GOVERNOR
AND I JUST PITIFULLY WILL BE
REELECTED. IS THIS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION. PLANS TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN A COVERT
NINETEEN. BECAUSE NOTHING THAT
WAS BROUGHT FORWARD EITHER IN
THE LETTER WHEN THE MAY REVISE
OR IN YOUR COMMUNICATION HAS.
PUT FORWARD THAT WE WERE GOING
TO CHANGE OUR- PRACTICES WE GET
A LOT OF WE HEAR YOU BUT I'LL
JUST SAY EVEN AS OF LAST WEEK.
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
REFUSED TO MEET WITH ME. I WAS
I HAD A GROUP MEETING REQUEST
WHICH WAS TURNED DOWN BECAUSE
PEOPLE WERE TOO BUSY. AND I'M A
LITTLE BIT SURPRISED BECAUSE I
THOUGHT I WAS A BUSINESS PERSON
THIS BILL. SO COULD YOU ANSWER
MY QUESTION. WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS SPECIFIC MEETING REQUESTS
I WILL MAKE SURE TO CHECK OUT
NUMBER DURING THE MEETING
BECAUSE THE MIDDLE CLASS IS
TAKING CARE OF. IS THIS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO OPERATE.
DURING THIS CALL THE NINETEEN
PERIOD WHICH COULD LAST FOR THE
NEXT SIX PLUS YEARS. I THINK
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT WHAT IT
WAS YESTERDAY ANSWER. BUT WE
ARE WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE- AND SEE THE BEST WAY
TO MAKE IT WITH YOU I WILL SAY
THAT- THE LETTER THAT WE SENT
YESTERDAY I GOT AN ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT THAT. A
LETTER IS NOT FULL
COMMUNICATION BUT WE WORK VERY
HARD TO STRUCTURE A TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAD AVAILABLE TO SHARE-
WAS IN THAT WRITER LETTER BUT I
UNDERSTAND. WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND I'M GONNA MAKE SURE TO
SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
DEPRECIATE THAT SO WITH AGAIN
WE HAVE A PANDEMIC. THAT.
TOUCHES EVERY CALIFORNIA
TOUCHES EVERY PART OF THE STATE.
SO I THINK WHAT WHAT WE NEED TO
SEE IS. LATER LIMITATIONS TO
PARAMETERS I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE GOVERNOR TO HAVE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF AUTHORITY
TO SPEND FEDERAL FUNDING
ESPECIALLY FOR FUNDING THAT
WILL BE REIMBURSED FROM FEVER
THERE THERE WAS- A NUMBER OF
NOT A NUMBER BUT THEY WERE
DEFINITELY EXPENDITURES DURING
THIS PERIOD WHICH- WERE NOT.
REIMBURSED BY FEMA. BUT WORK IN
MY OPINION REGULAR BUDGET
EXPENDITURES YET THE
LEGISLATURE WAS NOT CONSULTED-
WAS NOT ADVISE SO WHAT WHAT I
SAY THE LEGISLATURE TO DOESN'T
MEAN THAT. A LEGISLATING FOR
WAS NOT TALK TO. WE HAVE A
PROCESS WE HAVE A LEADERSHIP
PROCESS WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
PROCESS SO TALKING TO ALL ONE
LEGISLATOR TALKING TO
LEGISLATORS DOES NOT IN MY
OPINION CONSTITUTE. ALSO TATIAN
THERE WE HAVE A SPECIFIC
PROCESS OF OUR CONSULTATION.
MEANS THROUGH OUR GOVERNMENTAL
HISTORY. SO YOU KNOW I THINK
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO SEE IS-
A LOT MORE SPECIFICS IN TERMS
OF. WHAT YOU NEED- AUTHORITY
FOR. BECAUSE THE WAY THIS-
EMERGENCY SPECIFIED YOU COULD
SPEND MONEY ON ANYTHING TO DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT AND JUSTIFY
THAT IT HAS AN IMPACT ON ANY
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS. DURING
THIS PANDEMIC WHICH AGAIN THE
STATE EMERGENCY COULD LAST FOR
SIX YEARS OR MORE. CITY YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW YOU COULD
ELIMINATE BECAUSE OF THE TO
NARROW THE EXPENDITURES BECAUSE
ALL I'LL SAY THIS WHEN WE- THE
BILL I BELIEVE ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH WHEN WE LEFT THE
IDEAL WAS. AND THE WAY THAT IT
WAS PROPOSED TO US. WITH THAT
THE EXPENDITURES WERE GOING TO
BE LIMITED TO AGAIN YEAH HEALTH
AND PUBLIC SAFETY SO IN OUR
MINDS IT WAS YOU KNOW PP.
HOSPITAL ROOMS. YOU KNOW PEOPLE
FIVE GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET. SO AGAIN I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
DOING OUR PROPER OVERSIGHT OVER
SOME OF THESE CONTRACTS. I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS
DISPUTING THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNOR NEEDED TO TAKE A
CREDIBLE LEADERSHIP THAT WE
ASK. YOU KNOW WE- ARE NEED
NEEDED TO GO AFTER PP AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS VERY
CHALLENGING CHALLENGING TIMES
AND NO ONE'S. NOT NO WONDER SIR
CORRECTING THAT ISSUE- FOR THE
GOVERNOR DID MADE IT YOU KNOW I
THINK EVERYTHING HE DID I
PERSONALLY AGREE WITH. THE
PROCESS IN WHICH IT WAS DONE. I
THINK WAS VERY CONCERNING. SO
AGAIN AGAIN KNOWING THAT WE MAY
BE IN THIS STATE FOR A WHILE.
IT CAN NOW- COVE IN NINETEEN.
SITUATION IS TO ME BECOMING
MORE SIMILAR TO. HEART DISEASE
AND CANCER WHICH ARE ALSO A
MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE TO HAVE TO LIVE WITH.
WHAT WHAT THINKING HAS BEEN
DONE TO. PERHAPS PROPOSED OR TO
CREATE A GREATER SCOPE
LIMITATION. YEAH I'LL MAKE TWO
POINTS- ON THAT AND HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY FOLLOW UP SERVE
THEIR PARTS OF THE QUESTION
THAT I DIDN'T GET TO SUFFICIENT
WEIGHT I THINK THE FIRST IS
THAT WE VERY MUCH WANTED TO DO
OUR BEST ESTIMATE WITH THE
NEIGHBOR VISION AND HEADING
INTO THIS ONE NOT TO WEAR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FINALIZE THE BUDGET WE KNOW
THAT THAT NUMBER WILL CHANGE-
BUT WE THOUGHT IT'S IMPORTANT-
GIVING AT THAT PRIVACY OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS- THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT WE EXPECTED THAT
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE TO BE-
THAT THAT CAN BE DISCUSSED AND
DEBATED THROUGH THIS BUDGET
PROCESS INCLUDING HEARINGS LIKE
THIS AND SO THAT'S WHY. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING UP TO THE MAYOR
AND THEN OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
USED TO CLARIFY AS BEST WE CAN
THOSE EXPENDITURES THE SECOND
POINT IS WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
EXPENDITURES IN THE BUDGET YEAR
THIS COMING YEAR- I THINK WE-
BELIEVE THAT THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN SESSION AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY HOPING THAT
TRENDS WILL CONTINUE- WHERE
THERE WON'T BE A RESURGENCE
LIKE- LIKE YOU SOME PEOPLE FEAR
THAT THESE THINGS CAN WORK
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE PROCESS
EXCEPT THAT THESE EXPENDITURES
ARE PREDICTABLE AND I KNOW
MISTER CHAIR YOU MADE AND IT'S
ALL DUE TO HEART DISEASE. OR
CANCER AND OF COURSE- AT ALL
NOW- THESE ARE CHANGING ALL
SORTS OF WAYS BUT I IMAGINE
THAT I WANT TO SPEAK TOO FAR
OUT OF TURN THAT THERE IS A
SOMEWHAT PREDICTABLE PATH IN
TERMS OF NUMBER OF DEATHS FROM
YEAR TO YEAR AND NOT
NECESSARILY A SIGNIFICANT
DEGREE AT VARIANCE WITH COLBERT
NINETEEN THE TRUTH IS I THINK
THAT PREDICTABILITY- IS NOT
KNOWN YET BECAUSE SO MUCH OF
THE VIRUSES ON DOWN SO YOU CAN
HAVE ONE TEN THE DEBTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN NEXT YEAR THAT
WE HAVE THIS YEAR YOU COULD
HAVE TEN TIMES THAT NUMBER NEXT
YEAR COMPARED TO YOURS AND SO
THAT. WERE WORRIED ABOUT THAT'S
WHAT KEEPS US UP AT NIGHT SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH THAT AT BROUGH LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS OF COURSE THEN THERE
ISN'T A NEED TO RESORT TO ADD
EXTRA FINDING OUT BEYOND- WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING. AT A PROPOSED IN
JUST BY. AND THE ONLY. THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TO. SEX LANGUAGES AN
EMERGENCY PROVISION. ARE INDEED.
THAT WE HAVE TO MOVE VERY FOR.
TO GET AHEAD OF A RESURGENCE OF
THIS CASE BUT CERTAINLY- NOBODY
MORE THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
AND I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
SHARES THIS GOAL WITH YOU. UP
WE WANT THIS EMERGENCY TO GO
AWAY I JUST AS MUCH AS YOU DO
AND SO I KNOW WE'RE COMMITTED
TO DOING WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. NO WE DEFINITELY.
101% AGREE ON THAT- I THINK.
LOOK THE GOOD THE GOVERNOR
COULD CALL. A COVERT NINETEEN
SPECIAL SESSION- THROUGH THE
FALL HE HAS THAT AUTHORITY. HE
IS THE AUTHORITY TO BRING US
BACK OR **** TO COME BACK
WHATEVER. HI HE'S A WHICH IS
NOT ON THINK THERE'S ANYBODY
HERE- OR ANY OF THE ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT I'VE HEARD THAT
HAVE BEEN. RETICENT TO. AGAIN
SERVE THEIR DUTY WHEN CALLED
UPON- HAVING SAID THAT THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF.
CONCERN REGARDING THE- BLANKET
AUTHORITY THAT IS BEING ASKED
ABOUT- AND I AND I DO- I WOULD.
ARGUE AGAIN- IF YOU TALK TO THE
DOCTORS. THIS IS A CORONAVIRUS
CORONAVIRUSES HAD BEEN VERY
PREVALENT THROUGHOUT- FOR QUITE
AWHILE AGAIN THE SIZE OF THE
CRIME VIRUS AND THE-
TRANSMISSION IS VERY DIFFERENT
AND ALSO THE IMPACT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON PEOPLE. BUT
MY ESTIMATION JUST LIKE WITH
ANYTHING ELSE IS THAT- WE WILL
BE WE NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN IN
THIS FOR A FEW MONTHS- WE CAN
ANTICIPATE I WOULD SAY ABOUT
80% OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING. IN TERMS OF VENTILATORS
PP E. HOSPITAL ROOMS HOW WE
MANAGE THE HOMELESS- I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT ALL THE SUN- WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING THROUGH A HUGE
DEVIATION OF THIS OBVIOUSLY- AS
WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE DISEASE
THERE THERE WILL BE CHANGES
THERE THIS THAT'S TOTALLY
UNDERSTANDABLE- BUT I GUESS THE
WAY THE BLANKET AUTHORITY WORKS
IS THAT. AND YOU KNOW ANY
ANYTHING CAN BE DONE WHENEVER
ANYBODY FEELS LIKE IT AND THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE TO EVEN GET
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL THEY JUST
NEED YOUR VACATION AND AGAIN
NOTIFICATION COULD JUST BE I
JUST HIT SEND ON THE EMAIL
BUTTON. SO AGAIN JUST GOING
BACK TO MY FIRST POINT IN THE
QUESTION THAT YOU DIDN'T ANSWER
WHICH WAS- ON. IT IN ORDER FOR
THIS. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
THERE'S GONNA HAVE TO BE
SIGNIFICANT PROCESS CHANGES OF
WHICH HAVE NOT BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD EITHER IN THE REVISION.
OR IDEAS BUT THAT'S GONNA HAVE
TO BE. ABSOLUTELY BROUGHT
FORWARD THE OTHER CONCERNING
THING IS THE LITTERING OF
CONTROL SECTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET. MANY OF WHICH HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH. THE
PANDEMIC I JUST HAVE ONE
EXAMPLE AROUND THE GREENHOUSE
GAS. REDUCTION FUND SO WHY WHY
ARE THERE SO MANY SECTIONS OF
THE BUDGET THAT HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH COVERED NINETEEN. WELL
WHY IS THERE ARE BEEN THIS
DESIRE TO PUT IN ALL THESE
CONTROL CONTROL. SECTIONS TO
HAMPER FUTURE ADMINISTRATIONS
HAMPER FUTURE LEGISLATORS FROM
MAKING. BUDGET DECISIONS AND IF
YOU COULD IF YOU COULD SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT ONE FOR
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND. IT WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT
JUST ALSO TALK ABOUT THE- THE
DESIRE TO HAVE- CONTROL
SECTIONS ALL OVER THE BUDGET.
YES SO I'LL SPEAK TO THE
BROADER QUESTION AND I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FINE I THINK THE
REASON FOR THESE ADDITIONAL
CONTROL SECTIONS. NUMBER ONE
SOME OF THEM RELATE TO THE
FEDERAL FUNDING AND SPENDING
BUT I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES NUMBER TWO A LOT OF
THESE PROGRAMS- ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND WE KNOW WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO. MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS- BUT THE TRUTH IS
AND THIS IS A TRUE ACROSS THE
BUDGET THAT BE REVENUE TO
SUSTAIN THOSE INVESTMENTS IS
HIGHLY UNCERTAIN REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE UNCERTAIN EVERY
YEAR BUT THIS YEAR MUCH MORE
UNCERTAIN THAN MOST AND WHILE
YOU KNOW. WE MAKE OUR
PROJECTIONS IT'S HARD TO MAKE
PREDICTIONS BUT THERE IS A
STRONG POSSIBILITY THAT THAT
CAP AND TRADE REVENUE- THAT
FINDS THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS FIND WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER- THIS
COMING YEAR ND WE PROJECTED
BACK IN JANUARY AND SO THE
CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE. IS A
PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OUT HOW
TO GOVERN THE USE OF FUNDS IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE REVENUE
COMES IN DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WE
MIGHT HAVE EXPECTED BEFORE I
THINK THE ONE THING I'LL SAY.
IS THAT WHEN IT COMES TO FUTURE
LEGISLATORS FUTURE
ADMINISTRATIONS HI THIS CONTROL
SECTION IS OUR PROPOSAL ON IT
IS IN STATUTES AND IF
CONDITIONS CHANGE WE DO OUR
BEST TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT WITHIN
THE CONTROL SECTION IS ITSELF
BUT OF COURSE HAPPY TO. TAKE
ANY FEEDBACK ON HOW TO IMPROVE
THOSE BUT THOSE CONTROLS
ACTIONS CAN ALSO BE MODIFIED BY
A TEACHER OR EVEN THE CURRENT
LEGISLATURE BUT ON THE SPECIFIC
QUESTION THAT YOU RAISED. LET
ME TURN IT OVER TO THERESA.
HELLO ON THAT THEIR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION BY AND CONTROL
SECTION. IF YOU HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED- BUT IT IS AN EXISTING
CONTROL SECTION THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT THAT DOES
PERTAIN TO THE EXPENDITURE AND
COMMITMENT OF- CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS. YEAH BUT WE
ARE TRYING TO BE REALLY
EXPLICIT AND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF CHANGES TO REALLY BE VERY
EXPLICIT ABOUT THE MECHANISM.
THAT WE PROPOSE TO USE- ONCE WE
HAVE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT THAT. OPTION PROCEEDS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE COMING IN
THROUGH THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR. WELL I AGREE WITH
YOU I HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED AS WELL. I
DON'T KNOW THE WILL BE AGREEING
ON THEM SO JUST GOING BACK TO
THE MISTER VS ONE NATHAN- AGAIN
ON THE ONE THING WE KNOW ABOUT
A BUDGET IS WE'RE GONNA BE
WRONG DOESN'T CHANGE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR WE KNOW. YOU KNOW
WE KNOW THAT SOMETIMES WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA OVER ALLOCATE
WITHIN IS WE'RE GONNA UNDER
ALLOCATE. THAT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S- CHANGED. FROM BEFORE
WAS BUDGETARY NOT GONNA CHANGE
AFTER BEEN BUT IT SURE THAT'S
THAT'S THE BUDGET PROCESS A
BUDGET IS. OUR BEST GAS- TO.
ABOUT BEST GUEST OF
EXPENDITURES BUT WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS WHY YOU SEE THE
NEED TO- BASICALLY CUT OUT THE
PUBLIC CUT OUT THE LEGISLATURE
FROM THAT FUTURE DELIBERATION
AND I'VE ALSO SEE HERE'S HERE'S
THE BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS IN YOUR
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS. YOUR
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS HAPPEN IN
PRIVATE IN YOUR OFFICE. OUR
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS HAPPENED
HERE IN COMMITTEE IN PUBLIC IN
PUBLIC VIEW OF WHAT PUBLIC
COMMENT WITH PUBLIC FEEDBACK.
IT AND THAT'S THE WAY IT WAS
DESIGNED. RIGHT I MEAN YOU'RE
YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB AND WE'RE
DOING OUR JOB. BUT FOR FREE YOU
TAT NOT GET. PUBLIC FEEDBACK
NOT GET LEGISLATIVE. FEEDBACK
FOR THOSE ADJUSTMENTS AND FOR
THOSE TO BE HAPPENING. OUT OF
SIGHT I THINK IS. VERY
TROUBLING AND VERY CONCERNING I
THINK- I DON'T KNOW HOW HOW IN
DEPTH THE GOVERNOR WAS BRIEF
BUT- I DON'T KNOW THAT HE WOULD
AGREE WITH IT JUST BECAUSE-
LIKE I SAID BEFORE ON APRIL
TWENTIETH I THINK. YOU KNOW
YOUR OUR GOVERNOR IS WHAT
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST CHAMPION
OF TRANSPARENCY. THAT I KNOW I
MEAN HIS WHOLE CAREER HAS BEEN.
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING MORE
OPENNESS MORE TRANSPARENCY MORE
DATA MORE INFORMATION SO THE
FACT THAT. YOUR YOUR TRYING TO
ANTICIPATE SCENARIOS AND
ANTICIPATE ADJUSTMENTS FOR
SCENARIOS WHICH MAY HAPPEN. MAY
NOT HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE IS
VERY AN ORTHODOX BECAUSE THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE A BUDGET PROCESS-
WALL WE EVEN MY WHEN THEY ARE
BEING RECESSED THE GOVERNOR CAN
CALL AN EXTRAORDINARY SESSION.
WE'RE NOT IN RECESS WE CAN COME
BACK IN JANUARY MAKE ANY
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BUDGET THAT
IS NECESSARY. SO TO ME THESE
CONTROL SECTIONS ESPECIALLY
THAT AREN'T SPECIFICALLY IN
REGARDS TO THE- EMERGENCY SEEM.
VERY MUCH OUT OF PLACE AND A
HUGE OVERREACH OF AUTHORITY I
THINK I THINK THE L. L. AND I
FORGOT TO READ THE LA DOES-
QUOTE EARLIER. IS THAT THE I
WILL SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD GUARD ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN THE
FORTIES IS NOT SO MUCH A- AGAIN.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH ABOUT THE
EXPENDITURE I THINK IT IS THE
PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN SET UP SO
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN HAVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FEEDBACK THE
LEGISLATURE CAN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FEEDBACK WE DON'T HAVE A BUDGET
WITH- FIFTY THOUSAND CONTROL
SECTIONS BECAUSE MAYBE HIGHER
READ FUNDING CAME IN LAST OR
YOU KNOW CHILD CARE FUNDING
CAME IN MORE FOR HEALTH CARE-
ALL THIS AND YOU KNOW WE HAD
MORE MEDI CAL OR CAL WORKS-
ENROLLMENT THAN WE ANTICIPATED.
THAT IS THE BUDGET THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. YOU
KNOW IF WE WERE GOING TO BE
RIGHT ON THE MONEY WE STILL BE
IN VEGAS NOT HERE. SO AGAIN.
THIS IS VERY CONCERNING
ESPECIALLY. GIVEN THAT YOUR
AGENCY. HAS SHOWN A DISDAIN TO
PROPERLY COMMUNICATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. WHEN I SAY THE
LEGISLATURE I MEAN LEGISLATE
COURSE. SO AGAIN LET YOU YOU
CAN TALK TO ALL THE STAFF YOU
WALKED. BUT IF YOU'RE NOT
COMMUNICATING WITH ME OR MY
COLLEAGUES. THAT'S SUCH A WORD
THE LEGISLATURE. SO AGAIN THE
THERE WILL NEED TO BE I THINK-
VERY SERIOUS DISCUSSION OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS- IN ORDER TO
REALLY ADDRESS THESE ISSUES I
KNOW THAT- IN EVERY LEGISLATOR
THAT I'VE TALKED TO THERE IS A-
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF CONCERN.
REGARDING THE FUTURE OF THIS
PROCESS. HAVINGSAID THAT I
THINK THERE'S ALSO HE- HUGE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT WE WANT THE
GOVERNOR TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
WANT THE STATE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE BUT
WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT. WE
SHOULD- IGNORE THE LEGISLATURE
OR IGNORE THE PUBLIC.
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS SINCE
THE JUST TO SORT OF SUMMARIZE I
THINK WHAT WHAT WE NEED TO SEE
IS A- SIGNIFICANT. DEFINITION
OF SCOPE BECAUSE AGAIN IT MOST
EMERGENCY IF YOU HAVE A
GEOGRAPHIC DEFINITION AND YOU
HAVE A PROBLEM DEFINITIONS. SO
TO SAY IT ALL I GUESS WITH THE
WILD FAR YOU COULD YOU COULD
SAY ALL THESE THINGS COULD
HAPPEN OR COULD NOT HAPPEN. BUT
IN GENERAL THERE'S A VERY
SPECIFIC SCOPE IT THAT'S SEEN
AS REASONABLE WITH THE WITH
THIS PANDEMIC WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS STRETCH THE SCOPE. TO DO
ANYTHING. SO I THINK THAT YOUR
DEPARTMENT REALLY NEEDS TO
HUDDLE WITH ALL THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO REALLY HAVE MUCH
BETTER SCOPE DEFINITION AS TO
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND HOW YOU
INTEND TO SOLVE IT I THINK
AGAIN. ADJUSTMENTS CAN BE MADE
IN MID STREAM I DON'T THINK-
WILL WILL BE PASSED ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH- BUDGET BILL THAT WAS
DONE. I THINK IN A FEW YOU KNOW
IN IN IN A DAY OR TWO BECAUSE
OF THE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK WE- WE
DEMONSTRATED OUR ABILITY. TO
ACT VERY VERY QUICKLY- I WANTED
TO GO BACK FOR A SECOND. TO
INSTITUTIONALLY ONE
INSTITUTIONS THE DOCTOR WEBER
MENTION BUT ALSO THE OTHER
INSTITUTION OF- NURSING HOMES.
SO TO ME. I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT BOTH THE ACTION OR THE-
NOT NOT ENOUGH ACTION TAKING
PLACE IN BOTH THE NURSING HOME
SETTING BUT ALSO IN THE-
CORRECTIONS FACILITIES THE
PRISON SETTING. BECAUSE IN BOTH
OF THOSE SITUATIONS YOU HAVE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE NOT AMPLE
TORY MEANING THEY'RE NOT GOING
OUT THE PUBLIC THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO SHOP AT THE GROCERY
STORE THEY'RE NOT LEAVING THE
FACILITY. THE PEOPLE BRINGING
IN THE DISEASE ARE ALL THE
EMPLOYEES. AND I'M NOT BLAMING
THE EMPLOYEES I'M JUST THAT'S
JUST THAT'S JUST A FACT- YET
THERE HASN'T BEEN IN MY
OPINION- ENOUGH ACTION TAKEN
ESPECIALLY ON THE- CDC OUR SITE
I WAS I WAS PLEASED IN IN A
BRIEFING JUST THINK WAS
YESTERDAY. THAT THERE WAS MORE.
ACTION TAKEN ON THE NURSING
HOME SIDE BUT- BUT. IT WAS
STILL KIND OF BEING PLANNED IT
WAS NOT- IT WAS NOT A FIRM. AB
EXECUTION YET SO BOTH IN TERMS
OF CORRECTIONS AS WELL AS A
WITH NURSING HOMES HOW FAST IS
THE ADMINISTRATION PLANNING TO
ACT. TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
PROPER TESTING AND EVALUATION
OF EMPLOYEES AS THEY GO IN AND
OUT AND LET LET SOMEONE NURSING
HOMES BECAUSE MYSELF A COUPLE
THAT LEGISLATORS GOT BRIEF BUT
THIS THIS SPECIALLY WITH. WITH
OUR PRISON SYSTEM. ALL OF THE
PRESENT SYSTEM I KNOW THAT-
WHEN IT COMES TO BOTH THE LAY
OUT OF THESE FACILITIES IN USE
OF COMMON SPACES- TO IMPROVE
SOCIAL DISTANCING- AS WELL.
THANKS THOSE ARE TOP OF MIND I
DO NOT HAVE A THERE ARE
COLLEAGUES IDEA LAUGHS WE
SPECIALIZE IN THOSE ISSUES WITH
ME- SO I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT MISTER CHAIR.
THAT THAT'S FINE I THINK I
THINK JUST TO JUST TO TAKE THE
POINT HOME IS- AGAIN WE WANT TO
FOR THE SAFETY OF THE EMPLOYEES
AND FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
INMATES AND ALSO AS WELL AS FOR
THE NURSING HOME. RESIDENTS WE
NEED TO ESURE THAT THIS PROPER
TESTING. OF EMPLOYEES THERE HAS
TO BE REGULAR TESTING- THERE
HAS TO BE PROPER SAFETY.
PROTOCOLS FOR EACH OF THOSE.
PARTICULAR INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE
ONCE WE'VE SEEN ONCE- ONCE
COVERT NINETEEN AND THE BANANAS
TUITION COULD SPREADS. LIKE
WILDFIRE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
ANALOGY. NURSING HOME TELL US
YOUR NURSING HOME POSITIVE
TESTS ARE ONLY 3% ARE ONLY 3%
OF CORPORATE POSITIVE TESTS.
BUT YET THEY ARE 25% OF DEATHS
IN CALIFORNIA. SO THE STAKES
ARE ARE FAIRLY HIGH FOR EACH OF
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND AGAIN IN
NEITHER OF THESE RESIDENTS ARE
EMPLOYED TOWARD THE CAT THE CAT
MOVE AND MOVING THEM IS VERY
VERY DIFFICULT. SO I THINK I
CAN YOU KNOW WE WERE WE WERE
DEFINITELY INTERESTED IN
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO IDENTIFY HOW WE CAN. ASSIST
ON ALL THOSE ALL THOSE
INSTITUTIONS MOVING FORWARD.
OKAY I'M NOT SEEING ANY MORE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE- WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO A PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU
CANNOT FIND THE BOOTH- IT IS
NEAR THE NORTH STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL BY THE NORTH ENTRANCE
TO THE CAPITAL AND ELEVENTH AND
L. STREET. WE KNOW WE HAVE A
FEW PEOPLE THERE ARE GOING TO
LOOK TO THE PUBLIC ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE ROOM. I'M
SAYING NO PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN THE ROOM I'M GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN CAPITAL PARK
RIGHT NOW A FEW PEOPLE HAVE
CUTE. OKAY. YEAH THAT WAS A
HUNDRED AND HEAD OUT ALLOW OKAY.
TO DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
CAPITAL DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
CAPITAL PARK. I WELL I WAS TOLD
WE HAD SEVEN PEOPLE BEFORE.
YEAH GOOD. SUPPORTING
SUPPORTING YOUR YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
KNOW- OKAY I'M GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE WE WILL GO BACK TO
CAPITOL PARK IF WE HAVE ANYBODY
THAT IS GO TO THE PHONE I THINK
WE HAVE AN OPERATOR AGAIN THE
CALL IN NUMBERS 877-692-8957
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO EIGHT
THREE FOUR THREE EIGHT. EDDIE
IS OPERATOR YOU THERE DO WE
HAVE ANY. BUT YOU ON THE PHONE.
I WILL WAIT A FEW MINUTES IN
CASE WERE HAVING SOME
TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES. OBVIOUSLY
BEFORE RECESSING WE DON'T WANT
TO.
MODERATOR YOU THERE ON THE
PHONE. MODERATOR. MODERATOR
EITHER. I'M GONNA HOLD OFF TILL
AT LEAST WE GET CONFIRMATION TO
THE MODERATOR. MODERATOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME CAN YOU AT LEAST
RESPOND THAT YOU CAN HEAR ME
AND ARE CONNECTED TO US YET.
THIS IS THE EIGHTEEN ANTI
MODERATOR I CAN HEAR YOU AND I
AM CONNECTED CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES I CAN HEAR YOU DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN YOUR QUEUE. YES I
HVE A LINE OPEN RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
AND WE DO HAVE A LINE OPEN.
GREAT COULD COULD WE START WITH
THE FIRST PERSON. PLEASE
COMMENT AIRLINE IS OPEN. YEAH
IT MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
OKAY THANK YOU MY NAME IS MARTY
A MOTO ONE FAMILY MEMBER MY
OLDER SISTER AT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- WITH CD I'M THE
DIRECTOR TO YOU CAN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY YOU'RE COMING ACTION
NETWORK FIRST WANT TO THANK.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND ALSO THE
SUB COMMITTEE- STAFF FOR REALLY
DOING A GOOD JOB IN PUTTING
TOGETHER OF THE COMING UP
PUBLIC COMMENT- AVAILABILITY
YOU TO THE PHONE CALLS OR NEW
MET DATA OUT CAPITOL PARK. THE
STAFF TO BEEN REALLY TERRIFIC
IN ARRANGING ALL THAT WANT TO
SAY TAT WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR ADMINISTRATION AND
RESPONDING TO CO THAT NINETEEN.
BUT WE SUPPORT A STRONGER LEVEL
OVERSIGHT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS BY
THE LA- AND ALSO BY THE CHAIR
AND ON MISTER OPEN ALL MULTI
AND OTHERS- WE THINK THAT THIS
ALL DECISIONS REGARDING FUNDING
ESPECIALLY FOR. NEED TO BE
BALLOT NOT COULD ON THE FLOOR
BUT ON THE NEED TO RISK. TO AN
UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMIC. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES OLDER CALIFORNIANS
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND SUPPORT WORKERS ON THE
FRONT LINES LASTLY THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO LAY OUT. IN
ARIEL'S IN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. NEED TO BE MORE SAID
SUBMIT THERE NEEDS TO BE MRE
SPECIFIC ON RESTORING TRIGGER
IT CUTS. AND OVERSIGHT
ESPECIALLYBE MOUNTED
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS IS
LESS THAN THE AMOUNT PROJECTED
AS MR OBERNOLTE UP POINTED OUT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS. NEXT WE
ALSO THINK THAT HOW LATE IN THE
DAY BEFORE TRIGGERED A. PULLED
MEANING. FOR YOUR CALL. THANK
YOU. IN JULY OR- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOU
OUT WE HAVE WE'RE WE'RE TO GO
BACK TO THE MIGHT HELP WELL
MA'AM ONCE MAMAT CAN YOU HOLD
ON WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
CAPITOL PARK. THANK YOU CAN YOU
CAN YOU HEAR US OUTSIDE.
CAPITAL YEAH I CAN HEAR YOU CAN
YO HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
HAVE A MINUTE OUT THEY HAVE ME.
OKAY AWESOME YEAH. SO I HAVE I
HAVE A MINUTE. I'M HERE TO ABA
CUT AGAINST A- NEW I'M NOT
AMENDMENT TO CHANGE THE GAP-
AGE GAP FOR STUDENTS ON AND I
DON'T SCHOOLS I AM A STUDENT AT
TO HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY- CHARTER
SCHOOL AND- WE OFFER HE ARE
WITH MANY OTHER STUDENTS YOUR
EVERY MOST OF ON I SWEAR THAT
ALSO FOR YOU. FOR YOU TO READ.
WE ALL TRY TO BETTER MYSELF
AND- IF YOU. CUT THE I WILL GET
THE AGE GAP. OUTGOING MOST OF
US WILL BE UNABLE TO ATTEND THE
SCHOOL WILL BE CLOSED 92% ARE
OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN.
ALSO IF I THINK ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE COME FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES AND TRIED TO GET- THE
ENGLISH EDUCATION SO THAT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO- UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW ENGLISH DOWN ABLE TO
BECAUSE THEY GOT DOWN OVER
TWENTY SEVEN TRUST ME MOST OF
THEM I THAT VOLUNTEER ANOTHER
SCHOOL FOR AWHILE THANK YOU FOR
AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IS
UP THAT'S IT THAT'S IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WELL I HAVE MENDED
THIS SHOT MIRRORS SHORT. DON'T
DO IT OKAY THANK YOU. NEXT
SPEAKER THANK YOU. ID ARE MY
NAME IS NATALIE I. YEAH I CAME
FROM RUSSIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND THEY DID NOT
SPEAK ANY ENGLISH I WAS SO
AFRAID AND ANXIOUS WHEN TO BE
RAN OUTSIDE IN RESTAURANTS OR
GROCERY STORES. SO I ENROLLED
IN HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AND THEY TOUCH ME
ENGLISH SO WELL THAT AFTER ONE
YEAR AND THAT SCHOOL I DIDN'T
NEED ANY ESL CLASSES IN COLLEGE
I JUST TOOK OUR- REGULAR
CLASSES WITH AMERICANS AND I
WAS AT THE SAME LEVEL WITH THEM.
ALSO I HAD A DREAM THAT I WAS
THAT I SAW IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE BECAUSE I'M
THIRTY AND IT'S TOO LATE. BUT
MY FIRST TEACHER AT THAT
SCHOOL- MADE A MIRACLE THEY
MADE ME BELIEVE IN MYSELF SO I
WANTED TO BE IN ITS ROBOTIC
DOCTOR. AND I AM ON WEIGHT BG
IN THE DRAMATIC MEDICINE I'M A
VOLUNTEER AND SACRAMENTO BUDGET
MEDICAL CENTER. AND ALSO I WORK
AND PAY TAXES. SOLD MY LIFE
CHANGED TOTALLY AFTER I ENROLL
IN HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL SO AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
SUCH STUDENTS LAKE MI SO PLEASE
DON'T DO IT DON'T COULD USE THE
AGE OF THE STUDENTS IN HARTER
SCHOOLS. BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR SUCH PEOPLE LIKE
ME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. AS WE GO MORE
FAIR. THANK YOU PLEASE PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU. PLEASE START
HELLO MY NAME IS SAPPHIRE
JACKSON ANIMAL PRESENT STUDENT
AT THE HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY
CHARTER TECHNOLOGY SCHOOL AND-
I REALLY HAD A ROUGH TIME
TRYING TO GET MY EDUCATION
BECAUSE- I MEAN I WAS MARRIED
YET EVEN FORCED INTO MARRIAGE
AT A YOUNG AGE. TO ABUSIVE MAN
WHEN I GOT AWAY WITH HIM I WENT
TO SCHOOL SO THAT I COULD LEARN
A TRADE TO SUPPORT MY CHILDREN.
AND IT DOES DIDN'T GO WHY IN
THEN SO I JUST WORKED AND
WORKED AND WORKED AND THEN I
WANTED TO CHANGE MY JOB. SO I
WENT TO ANTHEM COLLEGE IN
RANCHO CORDOVA CALIFORNIA AND
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A SCAM. I
AM OR NOT I STILL THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND I DIDN'T
LEARN ANYTHING WHEN THEY CLOSED
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO TURN
ON THE COMPUTER. SO THEN I
FOUND OUT ABOUT HIGHLANDS AND I
STARTED GOING THERE AND BUILD
MY CONFIDENCE- GETTING MY
CREDIT SO I CAN- GRADUATE. AND
I FOUND OUT OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY HAVE THERE SO I. JOY
THOSE CLASSES AND- PASS THOSE
CLASSES IN. I NEVER THOUGHT OF
GOING TO COLLEGE WHEN I WAS A
KID BUT I WOULD LIKE TO TEN
ASHER COLLEGE BUT- THAT WILL BE
POSSIBLE IF THIS BILL PASSES
BECAUSE- AS YOU CAN SEE. I'M
NOT TWENTY SEVEN- AND DO.
HIGHLANDS WOULD BE GONE BECAUSE
I CARE ABOUT OLDER THAN TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD. SO THE
PRESSURE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PRESSURE. NEXT BAKER PLACE.
HELLO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MY
POSITION ON H. COBRA FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS MY NAME IS
FATIMA FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
THE- NOW I'M A HIGHLANDS IS THE
STUDENTS TO AND- I WILL WIN I
WENT AND I CAME TO U. S. AIDID
AND I KNOW AND YOU THINK A VOTE
THE EVERYTHING AND THE- I KNEW
A LITTLE BIT ENGLISH AND THE
MOON I KNEW A LITTLE BIT
ENGLISH AND I HAD MANY PROBLEMS
SUCH AS CHILDREN AND TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM AND BEING A WIFE
AND- WITH. THESE PROBLEMS A LOW
LITERACY AND BY THE AFTER THAT
I DECIDED TO IMPROVE MY
EDUCATION SO I TALKED WITH MY
FRIEND- SHE IS THE AN EMPLOYEE
OF HIGHLANDS AND SHE INTRODUCED
THE HOLOLENS TO ME- IT SILENCE
HEALTH. A IN AN AMAZING TO YOU
I IMPROVE MY ENGLISH IS GOALS
AND DELIVER MANY THINGS ABOUT
AMERICAN CULTURES AND AS A I
WAS AND HE'LL THESE STUDENTS
RIGHT NOW FOR A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT I AM PRO I PRO IS OF
THAT AND. AT AS I AM AT OF
GOING. AND AMONG. I HAD MADE. A
pWHY. AND TANKS TO HOLLA. AND
THE TANK FOR MANY UPPER. IS
THIS GIVE GIVE TO US MAN WITH
THESE GREAT OPPORTUNITY IS A
BRIDE IF YOU. WHAT IT ALWAYS
FOR ME PLEASE DON'T TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS A ME AND ALL OF
A IMMIGRANTS AND- ESPECIALLY
THE MAYOR THE PEOPLES OF WHO
ARE AL WERE- TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD BECAUSE WE NEED. TO
LEARN AND GROW- PLEASE DON'T
PUT THE AGE- THEN THE EACH CUP
OF A FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS THANK
YOU HIGHLANDS AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS NOW
IN A BIZARRE THAT I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT IN HIGHLAND CAME
TO CHARTER SCHOOL I AM HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT CAP AGE AND
THAT FOR CHARTER SCHOOL WHEN I
GET A INTRO TO THE HIGHLANDS I
WAS OVER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD
SO I HAD THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE MY ENGLISH LANGUAGE TO
FIND A JOB SUPPORTING MY FAMILY
TO GET OUT OF THE TO THE NEW
SOCIETY AND WITH NEW CULTURE
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED JUST I GET
THE TRIAL ENDS. SO I WANT TO
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE THAT I
KNOW ALL OF THAT LIKE MOST THE
MOST OF THEIR STUDENT IN
HIGHLAND OUT OVER IT AND THEY
ARE IMMIGRANT AND THEY ARE OVER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD IF YOU
PUT IT ON IT THEY GOT MR. THERE
REALLY THERE IS A ONCE IN THEIR
ONCE A HE BECAUSE THEY ARE NEW
THE REALLY NEED THAT PLEASE
DON'T PUT A GAP ON A- I FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK.
OKAY HEY HELLO MY
NAME'S ASIA ASIA GARCIA I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY CONCERNS
OVER THE AGE AGE GAP SAID TAKE
TAKE PLACE IMMEDIATELY MY JERRY
WAS SCHOOL HAVE BEEN EASIEST
COMPLY TESTED ME ON A FEW
DIFFERENT PATHS. HOWEVER I AM A
STRONG BELIEVER THAT IT'S NEVER
TOO LATE. I KNEW IT WAS FINALLY
TIME FOR ME TO COMPLETE MY
EDUCATION JOURNEY AS THE REST
OF MY PEERS JUST LIKE MY PEERS
I WILL BE CONSIDERED AN
ELIGIBLE TO QUALIFY FOR A
PROGRAM. DUE TO MY AGE IF THE
PROGRAM IS CUT THE RESTRICTIONS
LIKE AGE GAP NOT ONLY WATER
DRINK ATTAIN OUR GOAL BE LOSS.
MAY BE THE LAST CHANCE FOR SOME
OF THE SOME OF US TO FINISH
SCHOOL. SINCE I BEGAN A PROGRAM
I HAVE COMPLETELY CHANGED MY
LIFE IT'S BEEN. FIFTEEN YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN OUT OF SCHOOL
AND I FOUND OUT THAT MY PLAN IS
A SPARKLY NEW JOY. IN BE HAT
MAY BE DUE TO YOUR DECISION. MY
DREAM TO BE AN ESTHETICIAN A
ROLE MODEL TO MUCH OF BY THE
YOUR HAND. WE AREN'T NUMBERS
WERE INDIVIDUAL WILL REALIZE
THE REAL STORY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. PLEASE PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
CECILIA I USE WHEN THEY SAY
THAT- HIGHLAND CHANGED MY LIFE
HI AGE OF FIFTY TWO IF YOU
WESTERN FOR HIGHLANDS ARE YOU
WORTH AND I ABLE TO GET A BIT
IS YEAH I HAVEN'T SEEN AS MY
HIGH SCHOOL. AND THANK YOU.
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS ON CAPITOL PARK.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
BACK TO THAT PHONE MODERATOR
MODERATE ARE YOU STILL THERE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME I CAN HEAR
YOU GREAT IF YOU COULD PATCH
THE FIRST PERSON THROUGH THANK
YOU. OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO LINE NUMBER TWELVE LINE
NUMBER TWELVE IF I CAN HAVE YOU
PRESS ONE ZERO TO GET BACK INTO
THE QUEUE. AGAIN THAT WAS LINE
ONE TWO. OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE
ONE NUMBER ELEVEN A LINE ONE
ONE THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS LYNN KIRSTIE CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY I'M WITH MATERNAL AND
CHILD HEALTH ACCESS TO THIS
MORNING WE SUBMITTED ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA BENEFIT HEALTH
NETWORK AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
COUNCIL THE LETTER WITH FORTY
AGENCIES SIGNERS ABOUT THE WORK
OF NAVIGATORS AND NOT THREE TO
REJECT THAT CáC. GIVE ME IN
THE BUDGET THE ASSISTANCE WITH
CRUCIAL MEDI CAL AND CAL- OTHER
HELP APPLICATIONS- YOU HAVE THE
OPINION MAY BE THAT WITH
SIMPLIFICATION- THINGS ARE MUCH
EASIER IN THE COMMUNITY BUT
THEY ARE NOT. PEOPLE STILL GET
THE RENEWAL PACKETS THEY THINK
THEY HAVE TO RENEW THEY CALL
THEIR FRANTIC- THEY WANT TO
KNOW HOW TO APPLY WE HAVE TWO
MILLION PEOPLE COMING UP ON A
POINT IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS. AND THEY NEED THE
ASSISTANCE IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT'S THERE WITH- THIS
LIFESAVING EGGS ASSISTANCE
REALLY IN ADDITION TO HELPING
WITH APPLICATIONS AND RENEWALS
WE ALSO HELP PEOPLE GET CASH
CARDS- PANDEMIC EBT CARDS
RENTAL SYSTEMS. HELP WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ASSISTANCE- I
DELIVER DIAPERS MYSELF TO A
WOMAN WHO CAN'T WALK FROM STORE
TO STORE BECAUSE AND SHE'S GOT
A KNEE INJURY FROM HER HUSBAND
BEATING HER. WE SPENT FOUR
HOURS TRANSLATING THREE WAYS
THE PS US BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A CUDDLE BOND OR KEEP
CHASE SPEAKER. FROM BUT PEOPLE
BEACON AND CENTRAL ATTENTION
ONCE- SO- I'M BEGGING YOU. TO
PUT THIS AT LEAST IN THE
TRIGGER CUTS COLUMN I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S- SET FOR. A
REINSTATEMENT IF THE FUNDING
COMES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT UP A LITTLE BIT HARD
FOR THE COMMUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND. INTERPRET SO IF YOU
COULD MAKE THAT CLARIFICATION
OR LET ME GO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR- ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT. THANK YOU. NEXT YES
I'M NUMBER TWO. IF YOU ARE
STILL THE CALL LINE IN TWELVE
WE HAVE YOU PRESSED THEN FOR.
OKAY I WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN. LINE ONE EIGHT
THE LINE IS OPEN. BENJAMIN
TREND WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK THERE ARE
THREE PRIORITIES WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE FENCE THE
BUDGET PROCESS FIRST TO REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE ADULT DENTAL
BENEFITS TO THE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN PARTIAL RESTORATION
LEVELS. PEOPLE'S LIVES HAVE
BEEN CHANGED BY THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS GUM TREATMENT AND
PARTIAL DENTURES HOPING TO THAT
BENEFIT CONTINUE SECOND WE ASK
THE LEGISLATURE WE IN STATE
FUNDING FOR THE LET ME HELP
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM. HELP
NAVIGATORS APART THE COMMUNITY
FACING WORKFORCE THAT IS
CURRENTLY HELPING PEOPLE TO GET
INTO HEALTHCARE IN THE FACE OF
THE MAN JOB LOCK AND ECONOMIC
INSTABILITY. THIRD WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THE
JANUARY POSSIBLE TO SUPPORT
HELP FOR ALL OF DOCUMENTS CAN.
OUT THE CHICKEN OUT WE GOT THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE OLDER
ADULTS WHO NEED ACCESS TO CARE
ESPECIALLY IN THE WAKE UP CALL
THE NINETEENTH- TYPE. THANK YOU.
AN NEXT WEEK WE HAVE NUMBER
NINETY THAT. A ONE IN NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AIR NAP THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
A PUBLIC ADVOCATE. I'D LIKE TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EQUITY
APPROACH TO THAT ME REVISION
AND TO THINK DR- DELIVERY
COMMENTS OF THE PANDEMIC IS NOT
FELT EQUALLY. RATHER VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT JUST LOW
INCOME AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED BY
THIS CRISIS. WE APPRECIATE
KNOWING THAT MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ARE WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT INVESTMENTS ARE
MADE WITH EQUITY AND MINE AND
UPLAND YOU FOR CAMPING FUNDING
TO PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
A NUMBER MCCARTY RAY IS DEEPLY
RE OPENING SCHOOLS OF THE VITAL
STAFF OF RE OPENING THE ECONOMY
A LAWYER RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS MUST BE
MADE A LINE OF SEVERE BUDGET
CUTS. WE URGE YOU TO KEEP
EQUITY AT THE FOREFRONT OF YOUR
DISCUSSION THE PROTECT FUNDING
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR THE
CHILDREN DO NOT BEAR THE BRUNT
OF THE FISCAL CRISIS. WE NEED
MORE RESOURCES TO MEDICARE
LEARNING LOCKED EXPERIENCE NOT
SEVERELY BY HIGHER NEEDS YOU
DIDN'T. WHO ARE UNDER RESOURCE
PRIOR TO THIS CRISIS WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR HIGH NEED STUDENTS
FROM FURTHER CUTS IN CHILE
INVEST IN OUR PHYSICAL ACADEMIC
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING. AT THI EXTRA TO RE OPEN
THIS. WE RECKON THAT THE LIGHT
ACT UPON THAT NO ADDITIONAL BUT
IF I'M HAVING. DISTRIBUTE BY
THE COURT TO EQUITY BASED
FORMULA AS WELL AS A DENTAL
ADDITION FUNDING FOR TWELVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT AND
I'M- GOING TO CHECK ONE TIME ON
THE- IF YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO
KEEP UP. PRESS THEN ZERO. ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR COMMENT. IT
WILL BE WITH YOU CAN YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME. A LOT OF CLASS.
YOU KNOW THE ONE DO YOU. WELL
I'VE WORKED IN THE FAR PART
HOURS. FOR IN A LIFE BEFORE I
AM HAVING WE'RE HERE TO GO
CHAMBER GOING ON THIS SITE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. IN THE. CHAIR WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE KEEP
TALKING. OKAY SURE WHAT I'M
GONNA RESPOND. MARTY'S REMARK
HE AND IT IS WELL AS OTHERS DO
YOU MAY. I WILL INVITE YOU ARE
YOU THINK YOU NEED TO LOOK AT
THE ENTIRE IN ORDER. TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE MEANS
REPORTER RIGHT NOW YOU ALSO
HAVE BE R. OFFICE THE ARMY IN
THE- WORLD IF YOU. USE BE
EMPLOYER RIGHT NOW. RIGHT NOW
WHAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED. SAM
AND RIGHT NOW ALL. CURRENT GOAL
DO YOU KNOW RAIMES. WE ARE
THING I WILL OFFER YOU IS BUT
BUT WE- YOU BETTER. MAYBE NAME.
WE UP RIGHT NOW IN THE- RIGHT
THERE ARE AND BUT YOU NEED TO
DO A BY JOB OF THE MONEY OVER.
BECAUSE FUNDING NEEDS TO BE
CONCERNED WHAT RIGHT NOW YOU
DYNAMIC. THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP
ARMS SO JULY FIRST. WE DO HURT
THE MAYOR POOR PUBLIC TODAY.
ALL IS GONNA BE BETTER NO I
WILL BE WHETHER IT SHOW I. ON
SUNDAY WHEN HE ENTERED
ATTEMPTED TO THE THEY
DEVELOPING THEIR ARE WORSE THAN.
AGAIN REGARDING. AB AND WANT TO
SEE YOU LEGISLATORS YOU YOU A
BETTER JOB WILL BE. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK AND WE
WILL TRY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT'S SPEAKER WE HAVE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU ANY OF
ANYBODY ELSE IN CAPITAL PARKER
WE DON'T WORK CAPITOL PARK.
GREAT OF WELL WE HAVE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN FORTY TWO A TWO
NO NO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
PHONE AND NOT HAVE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT A COUPLE PARKS WANT TO.
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
STAYING THROUGH ON A FRIDAY
AND- DOING THIS HEARING VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED AND WE'VE
DONE. THE GERMAN.
LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS CONCLUDES YOUR
TELECONFERENCE YOU MAY NOW.